I know it's early in the year, but we're already talking about our summer family trip. And you know we like to Airbnb. I know this. Well, we like to have a kitchen and I like to be able to walk out in my robe in the morning and have a cup of tea and as you call it, Jenna, I like a long runway. Yes. Well, you know, Lee is working in Oklahoma right now and we're going to come out to visit him and he got us a really nice Airbnb to stay in as a whole family. So that we could spread out, and everybody could sleep well. And then you feel like you're at home,
我知道今年才刚开始，但我们已经在讨论夏天的家庭旅行了。而且你知道我们喜欢用Airbnb。我当然知道。嗯，我们喜欢有厨房的房子，我喜欢早上穿着浴袍走出去喝杯茶，正如你所说的，珍娜，我喜欢很长的准备时间。是的。好吧，你知道，李现在在俄克拉荷马州工作，我们要去看望他，他给我们找了一个非常好的Airbnb，让我们全家人一起住。这样我们就能舒展开来，每个人都能睡个好觉。然后你会感觉就像在家一样，
even though you're in a different city. Lady, I don't wanna sleep in the same room as my whole family. That's why I can't do hotels great anymore. Yeah, cause you all bunk up, and share a bathroom. Yeah, I like the space. I like a refrigerator, a real refrigerator. I like to have snacks, as you know. I don't know this. Yes, I don't want to call room service. I want them right there. That's right.
尽管你身处另一个城市。天哪，我才不想和我的全家人睡在同一个房间里。这就是为什么我再也受不了住很棒的酒店了。对，因为你们都挤在一起，共用一个浴室。对，我喜欢空间。我喜欢冰箱，真正的冰箱。你知道的，我喜欢吃零食。我可不知道。是的，我不想叫客房服务。我想让零食就在手边。没错。
Yeah. Everyone were ladies who Airbnb I guess for your next adventure for your next vacation, maybe consider Airbnb. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hey there! Hi! Hi! It is a super fun day here at Office Ladies 6.0 because this week we are celebrating Jenna's birthday and in honor of it being your birthday it is all about Pam Beasley.
对。每个人都是爱用Airbnb的女士，我想为了你们的下一次冒险，为了你们的下一次假期，也许可以考虑一下Airbnb。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极办公室爱好者的播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量VFF的故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈6.0。大家好！嗨！嗨！在办公室辣妈6.0，这真的是超级有趣的一天，因为本周我们要庆祝珍娜的生日，为了纪念你的生日，今天的一切都关于帕姆·比斯利。
Lady, I walked into the studio today and I had to take a picture because the point of view, my microphone, it has a mountain of goodies. There are flowers, there's gift bags, there's muffins and a card with dogs and birthday hats, which I can't wait to open. I mean, my goodness. And there's gonna be more. There's gonna be cake, because we do birthdays here. We do them, and maybe in honor of Pam, there's also gonna be mixed berry yogurt for everybody.
天哪，我今天走进工作室时，不得不拍张照片，因为这个视角，我的麦克风，上面有一座零食山。有鲜花、礼品袋、松饼，还有一张带有狗狗和生日帽的卡片，我都迫不及待想打开它了。我是说，天哪。而且还有更多东西。会有蛋糕，因为我们这里会过生日。我们会庆祝，也许为了纪念帕姆，大家还会吃到混合浆果酸奶。
Ah, that's good. That's amazing. Oh my gosh, well, thank you, lady. You know, everyone, Angela and I thought that it would be fun to break down the all-abouts of our office characters on our birthday weeks this year. And my birthday is Friday. That's right.
啊，那太好了。太棒了。天哪，谢谢你，亲爱的。你知道吗，大家，安吉拉和我觉得，在今年我们生日的这一周里，把我们办公室角色的方方面面拆解开来会很有趣。我的生日是周五。没错。
So this is my week. This is your week, and it's also Pam's week. And before we get to Pam Beasley, let's celebrate your birthday. We have gifts, okay? I see there's a bag that says happy birthday and it's heavy. Okay, that's from me. Okay.
所以这是我的周。这是你的周，这也是帕姆的周。在我们在聊帕姆·比斯利之前，先来庆祝你的生日吧。我们有礼物，好吗？我看到有一个袋子上面写着生日快乐，而且很重。好吧，那是我的。好吧。
And I'll explain. It is a giant bag of sumo citrus oranges. Yes. And. And. It looks like a book lady. But guess what? What? It's like a gift box. And inside of it, book, lady, but guess what? What?
我来解释一下。这是一个装满凸柑的大袋子。对。还有。看起来像本书，亲爱的。但你猜怎么着？什么？它就像一个礼品盒。里面装着，书，亲爱的，但你猜怎么着？什么？
It's like a gift box and inside of it, okay, hear me out. I wanted to get you a book for your birthday, but I don't know what all you have and don't have and what's on your list. So I found this independent bookstore in Madison, Connecticut. It's called Just the Right Book. And you can fill out sort of like the taste of books you like, the subjects you like, and then you will get a book in the mail each month. You can sign up for a four month subscription or six month or 12 month. And Lady, I just love supporting this independent bookstore.
它就像一个礼品盒，里面装着，好吧，听我说。本想为你买本书当生日礼物，但我不知道你有哪些书，没有哪些书，也不知道你的书单上有什么。所以我找到了康涅狄格州麦迪逊的一家独立书店。它叫“正当好书”（Just the Right Book）。你可以填写你喜欢的书的口味、你喜欢的题材，然后你每个月都会在信箱里收到一本书。你可以注册四个月、六个月或十二个月的订阅。亲爱的，我就是喜欢支持这家独立书店。
I love reading, Angela. I know, I know. And this is like such a thoughtful gift. And I love this fakey book that I can hide things in. I know. It's, oh, I love a sneaky book. It says it looks like a real book. It really does. It's really pretty.
我喜欢读书，安吉拉。我知道，我知道。这真的是一份太贴心的礼物了。我喜欢这本可以用来藏东西的假书。我知道。噢，我太喜欢这种暗藏玄机的书了。它看起来像一本真书。真的太像了。非常漂亮。
Wow, you crushed it on the birthday gifts, Ann. Thanks. I'm gonna put a link to this bookstore. It's called Just the Right Book. And I just want to read one thing from its website. It says, in a world dominated by algorithms, think of Just the Right Book as your personal book stylist, a personalized bookseller experience based on you and delivered to you. Well maybe I should start sharing what I'm reading and we can do a little like book club
哇，安，你在生日礼物上真是太走心了。谢谢。我会在简介里放一个这家书店的链接。它叫“正当好书”。我只想朗读它网站上的一句话。它写道：在一个由算法主导的世界里，把“正当好书”想象成你的专属图书造型师，一个基于你并为你定制的个性化书商体验。也许我该开始分享我在读什么书，然后我们可以一起成立一个类似读书俱乐部的组织
with people. I would love to do a book club. And Sam and Cassie also got you stuff. Sure, I got you the most Michael Scott card I could find. Is it the dogs with the party hats? Mm-hmm, open it. Okay. It says happy birthday party animal.
和大家一起。我很乐意参加读书俱乐部。萨姆和卡西也给你准备了东西。当然，我给你找到了最符合迈克尔·斯科特风格的卡片。是戴着派对帽的狗狗那张吗？嗯哼，打开它。好吧。上面写着：生日快乐，派对动物。
Love Sam, Cassie, and Angela. I literally love it. Sam, that is the most Michael Scott card. Thank you. Who got the Trader Joe's gluten-free cinnamon coffee cake muffins? I did. Sam, Sam, you bought these for me way back at Earwolf.
爱你们的萨姆、卡西和安吉拉。我简直太喜欢了。萨姆，这真的是最像迈克尔·斯科特的卡片了。谢谢。谁拿了乔氏超市的无麸质肉桂咖啡蛋糕松饼？我拿的。萨姆，萨姆，你很久以前在Earwolf就给我买过这个。
Oh boy, I did. And I love you and hate you for this because they are so delicious, but they are like. Don't read the calories. I know. Don't read it. It's your birthday. It's your birthday.
哦天哪，我确实买过。我又爱又恨你送这个，因为它们太好吃了，但它们简直是……别看卡路里。我知道。别看。今天是你的生日。今天是你的生日。
Yeah, calories don't count until Saturday. Yeah, exactly. There you go. Well, thank you. I love these muffins and I will not buy them for myself. So thank you, but gift accepted. Sure. Yes, go. Well, thank you, I love these muffins and I will not buy them for myself, so thank you. But gift accepted. Sure.
对，卡路里到周六才开始计算。对，完全正确。就是这样。好吧，谢谢。我喜欢这些松饼，但我自己是不会买的。所以谢谢你，不过礼物我收下了。当然。没错，去吧。好吧，谢谢，我喜欢这些松饼，但我自己是不会买的，所以谢谢你。不过礼物我收下了。当然。
Yes, Jenna, I got you the calorie free roses. Thank you so much, Cassie, I do love roses. And just to talk about books, I'm reading a book right now that Angela, I think you might really like. It's called The Backyard Bird Chronicles. And it's written by Amy Tan, who wrote Joy Luck Club. Joy Luck Club, yes.
是的，珍娜，我给你准备了零卡路里的玫瑰花。非常感谢，卡西，我确实很喜欢玫瑰。说到书，我最近正在读一本书，安吉拉，我觉得你可能会真的很喜欢。它叫《后院观鸟记》（The Backyard Bird Chronicles）。作者是谭恩美，她写过《喜福会》。《喜福会》，是的。
And it's just about her sitting in her backyard, learning all the birds and drawing them and just talking about the personalities. And becoming my best friend. Exactly. I have lots of books to read now. Yay. And lady, there's one more thing I'd like you to open.
这本书讲述了她坐在后院里，认识所有的鸟类、画下它们，并讲述它们的性格。然后变成了我最好的朋友。没错。我现在有好多书要读了。耶。亲爱的，还有一件事我想让你打开。
You know, a while back we were going through fan mail and I saw this and I thought this will be perfect when we do all about Pam Beasley. These are handmade earrings from an artist in Ohio, Redleaf Studio. Look at the Pam teapot. Oh my gosh, it's a teapot and it has a letter and a little pencil and some hot sauce and
你知道，不久前我们在看粉丝来信时我看到了这个，我想当我们制作“帕姆·比斯利专场”时，这会是完美的礼物。这是俄亥俄州一位艺术家手工制作的耳环，来自红叶工作室（Redleaf Studio）。看看这个帕姆的茶壶。噢天哪，这是一个茶壶，上面还有一封信、一支小铅笔、一些辣酱，以及
a little timer. Yeah. All the things that were in the teapot. I know. And she made little sprinkles cat earrings for me as well. I'm going to share her shop. She is so talented. Handmade from Ohio.
一个小定时器。对。茶壶里所有的东西。我知道。她还为我制作了小洒水猫耳环。我要分享她的店铺。她太有才华了。来自俄亥俄的手工制品。
What's her store again? Red Leaves Studio. Thank you so much. Yeah. Wow. This is fun, Angela. But this is also getting me excited for when we do all about Angela Martin and celebrate your birthday. Well, I'm not done.
她的店叫什么名字来着？红叶工作室。非常感谢。哇。这太有趣了，安吉拉。但这同时也让我为我们制作“安吉拉·马丁专场”并庆祝你的生日感到兴奋。好吧，我还没说完。
What? In honor of it being all about Pam Beasley, my favorite part about Pam is her Pam-Sass. We'll get to it. But lady, I had to bust out. How do you even have a Pam Sass t-shirt? I thought you only had Angela Sass. No, I bought Pam Sass too. You love the Sass.
什么？为了纪念帕姆·比斯利专场，我最喜欢帕姆的地方就是她的“帕姆式毒舌”（Pam-Sass）。我们待会儿会聊到。不过亲爱的，我得把这个拿出来。你怎么会有一件“帕姆毒舌”T恤？我以为你只有“安吉拉毒舌”呢。不，我也买了帕姆毒舌。你太喜欢这种毒舌了。
I love the Sass. And of course there is cake and there's mixed berry yogurt. We'll have all of that on our break. And I guess muffins too and oranges. We have a lot to eat and drink. Thank you everybody. This was wonderful. I feel this is a great birthday kickoff. Well you deserve to be celebrated and we love you. Well thank you. Okay so let's get to all about Pam Beasley. I thought I would kick off today's episode with this request from Mel E in Richmond, Texas.
我太喜欢这种毒舌了。当然还有蛋糕和混合浆果酸奶。我们休息时会享用所有这些。我想还有松饼和橙子。我们有很多吃的喝的。谢谢大家。这太棒了。我觉得这是一个很好的生日开端。好吧，你值得被庆祝，我们爱你。谢谢。好吧，那我们来聊聊帕姆·比斯利吧。我想用德克萨斯州里士满的梅尔·E（Mel E）的这个请求来开启今天的节目。
Mel wrote in and said, please read the show Bible entry for Pam. Guess what everyone, Jenna sent me the show Bible. I did. Can we take this opportunity really quickly for me to explain? Yes. I worry that maybe I have misrepresented the show Bible. Or maybe I have because I had never really seen it. So the show Bible is simply a list of facts about each character as they are revealed in an episode that has aired. So there will never be anything in the show Bible that wasn't also on the show.
梅尔来信说，请朗读帕姆的剧集圣经条目。大家猜怎么着，珍娜把剧集圣经发给我了。没错。我们能借此机会让我非常快速地解释一下吗？可以。我担心我可能误导了大家对剧集圣经的看法。或者我确实误导了，因为我以前从未真正看过它。所以剧集圣经实际上只是关于每个角色的事实列表，这些事实是在已经播出的剧集中展现出来的。因此，剧集圣经中永远不会出现剧中没有提及的内容。
That's true. It's what exists in the canon. Yes. But I have to say it's really fun to see it all listed out because you forget things. Completely. It's so helpful. And you know, Jenna, when you did show Bibles for Kevin Malone and Michael Scott, you sort of grouped the information in different pairings. Yes, I did the same thing. But you know, our brains work differently. So here's the way I'm going to share the show Bible info for Pam Beasley. Pam's full name is Pamela Morgan Halpert, formerly Beasley.
没错。这就是官方设定中存在的内容。是的。但我必须说，看到它们全部列出来真的很有趣，因为你会忘掉一些事情。完全是这样。这太有用了。而且你知道吗，珍娜，当你为凯文·马龙和迈克尔·斯科特制作剧集圣经时，你把信息分成了不同的组合。是的，我也做了同样的事情。但你知道，我们的脑回路是不一样的。所以我分享帕姆·比斯利剧集圣经信息的方式是这样的：帕姆的全名是帕梅拉·摩根·哈尔珀特，原姓比斯利。
She is Presbyterian. Her address is 383 Linden Avenue in Scranton, Pennsylvania. She drives a silver Subaru Outback. She is a slow driver, but she can drive a stick shift. Oh, yeah. See, I forgot that. She needs glasses, but usually wears contacts. Her instant messenger name is receptionitis 15. Her job titles at Dunder Mifflin were listed as receptionist, sales rep, and secret assistant to the regional manager by Dwight.
她是长老会信徒。她的住址是宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的林登大道383号。她开一辆银色的斯巴鲁傲虎。她开车很慢，但她会开手动挡。哦，对。你看，我都忘了这事。她需要戴眼镜，但通常戴隐形眼镜。她的即时通讯用户名是receptionitis 15。她在邓德米夫林的职位在剧中被列为前台、销售代表，以及由德怀特赋予的区域经理的秘密助理。
We know she goes on to become the office administrator, but that is not covered in the show Bible, because it stops. Yep, it stops after season six? Yeah, I think so. Around there, yeah. But I love this little piece of trivia. She worked at Dunder Mifflin before Jim.
我们知道她后来成为了办公室行政主管，但这并没有包含在剧集圣经中，因为它停更了。是的，它在第六季之后就停了？对，我想是的。差不多那个时候，吧。但我喜欢这个冷知识。她在吉姆之前就在邓德米夫林工作了。
See? Oh my gosh, this is always a hotly debated topic. Who worked there first? It's in Pam's show Bible. Okay. Then I did a segment called her skills and her quote needs improvement list. Oh. Her skills. She types 90 words a minute, is able to change a tire by herself, and is an accomplished volleyball player. Her needs improvement list. She has the lowest sales record in the office and the worst attitude. The worst attitude? Is that in the show Bible? It is! I did a direct copy and paste. What? About sales. I guess she has the worst attitude about sales. Oh I
看？天哪，这一直是一个激烈争论的话题。谁先在那儿工作的？这写在帕姆的剧集圣经里。好吧。接下来我有一个环节叫“她的技能”和“她的需要改进列表”。哦。她的技能。她打字速度是每分钟90个字，能够自己更换轮胎，并且是一名出色的排球运动员。她的需要改进列表。她在办公室的销售记录最低，而且态度最差。态度最差？剧集圣经里是这么写的吗？是的！我是直接复制粘贴的。什么？关于销售。我猜她对销售的态度最差。哦，我
don't even think that's true. Okay. Next on her needs improvement list her attempt at a southern accent sounds like Forrest Gump. Oh okay. She has won the following awards at the Dundee's. Longest engagement and widest sneakers. Here are some of her likes. Asian food, free-sell Sudoku, a house with the terrace upstairs to plant flowers on. She loves to draw to watch HGTV. She likes dogs over on. She loves to draw, to watch HGTV. She likes dogs over cats. She loves a sprinkle of cinnamon on her coffee, mixed berry yogurt, French onion chips, making copies.
甚至不觉得这是真的。好吧。接下来在她的需要改进列表里，她模仿南方口音听起来像阿甘。哦，好吧。她在邓迪奖上获得过以下奖项。最长订婚奖和最白运动鞋奖。以下是她的一些喜好。亚洲食物、数独游戏、一栋楼上带有露台可以种花的房子。她喜欢画画，喜欢看HGTV（全美家庭电视网）。比起猫，她更喜欢狗。她喜欢在咖啡里撒一点肉桂粉、混合浆果酸奶、法式洋葱薯片、复印文件。
That cracks me up. And she likes the following movies, Fargo, Edward Scissorhands, Days and Confused, Breakfast Club, The Princess Bride, and Legally Blonde. Yeah. Here are some of her dislikes. The Dundees. She considers it like a train wreck. Direct quote.
这把我逗笑了。她喜欢以下电影：《冰血暴》、《剪刀手爱德华》、《年少轻狂》、《早餐俱乐部》、《公主新娘》和《律政俏佳人》。是的。以下是她的一些厌恶。邓迪奖。她认为这简直是一场灾难。直接引语。
She doesn't like frisbee-based competition. Don't get your frizz on with Pam. She does not like hunting, ads for Six Flags with the creepy old guy dancing, pig Latin, country music, macanudos cigars, and she doesn't like to be called Pammy. She does not. Don't call me Pammy. Now I have a section I called, She is prone to shenanigans and pranks.
她不喜欢飞盘比赛。别跟帕姆玩飞盘那一套。她不喜欢打猎、带有毛骨悚然的老头跳舞的六旗游乐园广告、猪拉丁语（Pig Latin）、乡村音乐、麦卡努多雪茄，她还讨厌别人叫她帕姆米（Pammy）。她真的很讨厌。别叫我帕姆米。现在我有一个板块叫做：她倾向于搞恶作剧。
Oh, particularly with Jim. Here are just a few. She wrote graffiti about Michael on the bathroom wall. She tries to throw stuff in Dwight's coffee mug when he's away, like paper clips or messages for Dwight. I forgot about that. And with Jim, she posted Dwight's resume on job sites. She would sometimes hum the same high-pitched note with Jim to get Dwight to make an appointment with an ear doctor. That was very funny. She has been sending Dwight letters from the CIA
哦，特别是跟吉姆一起。以下只是其中几个。她在浴室墙上写了关于迈克尔的涂鸦。当德怀特不在时，她试图往他的咖啡杯里扔东西，比如回形针或给德怀特的留言。我都忘了这事了。她还和吉姆一起，把德怀特的简历发布到求职网站上。她有时会和吉姆哼唱同一个高音，以此来引诱德怀特去找耳鼻喉科医生预约看病。那真的非常搞笑。她一直给德怀特发送来自中央情报局的信件
saying they are considering him for a secret mission. And she also posed as the Dunder Mifflin Infinity computer system with Jim to prank Dwight. Next up, relationships. Oh. She would do Oscar or Toby. She was engaged to Roy for three years, and she considers Jim her soulmate. Yes, true.
声称他们正在考虑招募他执行一项秘密任务。她还曾和吉姆一起假冒邓德米夫林无限电脑系统来恶作剧德怀特。接下来是，人际关系。哦。她愿意和奥斯卡或托比约会。她和罗伊订婚三年，她认为吉姆是她的灵魂伴侣。是的，没错。
And one final thing before we go to break. People often ask us where our characters are now and what they're doing. And this is what the NBC website says about Pam. Oh! and what they're doing. And this is what the NBC website says about Pam. Oh, Pam merged her mural business with a local art gallery in Austin. Currently, she's on an artist retreat in New Mexico. Oh, I wonder when this was. Was this after the finale or something?
在进入休息前的最后一件事。人们经常问我们我们的角色现在在哪里，在做什么。这就是NBC网站上关于帕姆的介绍。哦！以及他们在做什么。这就是NBC网站上关于帕姆的介绍。哦，帕姆将她的壁画业务与奥斯汀的一家当地艺术画廊合并了。目前，她正在新墨西哥州参加一个艺术家静修会。哦，我很好奇这是什么时候的事。这是在大结局之后还是什么的？
Must be, because you're living in Austin. Yeah. Well, there you go. That is my show Bible breakdown, plus a little extra on All About Pam Beasley. I loved it. Do you ever think like what if you had like a show Bible for your life? What would the entries be? How cool that would be? Oh my gosh. You know what? That makes me think of those journals that are like one line a day journals, where you're supposed to just write one line a day. I always start those and I get about 15 days in and then I forget to do it. Yeah, I had one when Isabel was a toddler. It says something
一定是，因为你住在奥斯汀。好吧，就是这样。这就是我的剧集圣经解析，外加一点关于帕姆·比斯利专场的额外内容。我太喜欢了。你有没有想过，如果你的生活也有一本剧集圣经会怎么样？里面的条目会是什么？那该有多酷啊？天哪。你知道吗？这让我想起那些诸如“一日一行”的手帐，就是那种让你每天只写一行字的日记。我总是开始写，坚持大约15天左右，然后就忘了写了。对，伊莎贝尔还是幼儿的时候我有一本。上面写着诸如
like kids say the darndest things and you're supposed to write something they say each week. And I wrote a bunch in it and I go back and it's so sweet and cute and hilarious and such a snapshot of my life with her back then. Yeah. Aw. I know. Well, lady, thank you. Why don't we go to break and when we come back we'll keep talking all about Pam Beasley. I'm not gonna lie everyone, this is triggering my social anxiety a little bit. Why? It's such a spotlight. It's like my birthday and it's all about Pam Beasley and I'm feeling a little shy about
“小孩子说最绝的话”之类的话，让你每周写下一句他们说的话。我在上面写了很多，现在回去翻看，真是太甜蜜、太可爱、太爆笑了，那简直是我和她当时生活的缩影。是的。噢。我知道。好吧，亲爱的，谢谢你。我们为什么不先去休息一下，等我们回来后会继续聊所有关于帕姆·比斯利的事情。说实话，大家，这有点触发我的社交焦虑了。为什么？这太引人注目了。这就像是我的生日，而且一切都围绕着帕姆·比斯利，我对这一切感到有点害羞
it all, but let's do it. Well here's the thing, we're gonna have some mixed berry yogurt, that's gonna make you feel good, and then we're gonna talk about Pam. Not you, we're gonna talk about Pam. All right. Som then we're gonna talk about Pam. Not you, we're gonna talk about Pam. Like, someday you're gonna talk about Angela Martin. I am not gonna take it personal. When you all call her a bitch, I won't take it personal. All right, well, let's take a break
，但我们开始吧。好吧，事情是这样的，我们要吃点混合浆果酸奶，这会让你感觉好点，然后我们要聊帕姆。不是你，我们要聊帕姆。好吧。所以，然后我们要聊帕姆。不是你，我们要聊帕姆。就像，总有一天你们会聊安吉拉·马丁。我是不会往心里去的。当你们都叫她碧池时，我是不会往心里去的。好吧，那我们休息一下
and then we'll get to it. This episode is brought to you by IKEA. This episode is brought to you by IKEA. I could not be more excited to talk about IKEA. Lady, you leave me a lot of messages about IKEA, about your IKEA home projects, like you recently just did your guest bedroom. I love IKEA. I know you do. So here's the thing.
然后就开始吧。本集由宜家赞助播出。本集由宜家赞助播出。我对于聊宜家兴奋得无以复加。亲爱的，你给我留了好多关于宜家的信息，关于你的宜家家居项目，比如你最近刚搞定的客房。我爱宜家。我知道你爱。所以事情是这样的。
We have this garage that we converted into a guest room, but it was a garage. It had like a concrete floor. It was not very cozy. And you know when my mom and sisters come out, I wanted a nice cozy place for them when they visit. So we went to IKEA and we got everything you need to make a nice cozy retreat.
我们把这个车库改造成了一个客房，但它曾经是个车库。里面有水泥地面。不是很温馨。你知道当我的妈妈和姐姐们来的时候，我希望她们来访时能有一个温馨舒适的地方。所以我们去了宜家，买齐了打造一个温馨休憩之所所需的一切。
Well, Ange, I just love how thoughtful you were in putting this room together. And IKEA points out that sleep is very personal. In fact, IKEA sells six sleep essentials. Sound, light, air quality, comfort, declutter, and temperature. So this is their thing and they say creating your optimal mix of essentials will help you to relax and will contribute to better sleep. So I have to ask you, Angela, how did you apply the six IKEA Sleep Essentials to your design of this room?
安吉，我太喜欢你在布置这个房间时所表现出的体贴了。宜家指出，睡眠是非常私人的。事实上，宜家出售六大睡眠要素。声音、光线、空气质量、舒适度、去除杂物和温度。所以这是他们的核心理念，他们表示，打造最适合你的要素组合将帮助你放松并有助于获得更好的睡眠。所以我不得不问你，安吉拉，你是如何将宜家的六大睡眠要素应用到这个房间的设计中的？
Well, what's so funny is that I didn't even know I was doing it, but I did it. Yes, I think just by going to IKEA, you hit on these essentials. Well, since our guest room was once a garage and we wanted it to be a cozy guest room, but also like a teen hangout space. Yeah. We really focused on declutter, comfort and light.
有趣的是，我甚至不知道自己在这么做，但我确实做到了。是的，我想只要去宜家，你自然就会接触到这些要素。因为我们的客房曾经是个车库，我们希望它成为一个舒适的客房，但同时也是一个青少年的聚会空间。是的。我们真的把重点放在了去除杂物、舒适度和光线上。
Okay. So first we had to declutter it. We had all of these board games, things like that. We got IKEA bookshelves to organize all the games and the movies we had out there. We put a super we had out there. We put a super comfy couch out there and a twin day bed. We also have a little coffee table and a credenza that we put a small TV on. What I loved about the IKEA credenza is it's got these cubby doors on the bottom so we
所以首先我们得清理杂物。我们有各种桌游之类的东西。我们买了宜家的书架来整理我们在那里的所有游戏和电影。我们放了一个超级我们在那儿放了一个超级舒服的沙发和一个双人日床。我们还有一个小茶几和一个放着小电视的矮柜。我喜欢宜家矮柜的地方在于，它的底部有这些小柜门，所以我们
had more storage. We actually put all the bedding, which we got from IKEA, in the credenza. So it's all ready to go. It's all out there. That's right. Smart. But we really needed to warm that space up so I also got a comfy rug and I got an end table and I got a lamp. We basically turned it into like a little mini studio apartment and it's really just a cozy place for our company when they visit and it's great for our teenagers when they have sleepovers and hangouts. Josh put together every single piece of furniture in there by himself. I remember these messages.
有更多的储物空间。事实上，我们把所有从宜家买来的床上用品都放进了矮柜里。所以一切都准备就绪。全都在那里了。没错。真聪明。但我们真的需要让那个空间暖和起来，所以我还买了一块舒服的地毯，买了一个边几，买了一盏灯。我们基本上把它变成了一个小型单身公寓，对于来访的客人来说，这里真的是一个温馨的地方，对于我们的青少年来说，这里也非常适合他们开睡衣派对和聚会。乔治一个人把里面所有的家具都组装好了。我还记得这些信息。
Yeah, he's really good at putting IKEA furniture together. I think he kind of likes it. I just want to throw that out there. I think he is excited to do it. I'll ask him. Okay. And you know, we just love how it turned out. Our teenagers love it and so do my mom and sisters when they visit. My mom says it's her favorite room in our house. Wow! The converted garage. Well I got a tour the last time I was at your place and it really is quite the transformation. You guys did a great job. I would sleep there and lady I am at an age and a season of life where comfortable sleep is very important to me so it gets my seal of approval. And I just love the IKEA list for how to craft the perfect sleep.
对，他很擅长组装宜家的家具。我觉得他挺喜欢干这个的。我想顺便提一下。我觉得他做这个挺带劲的。我去问问他。好的。你知道的，我们太喜欢改造后的效果了。我们的青少年很喜欢，我妈妈和姐姐来的时候也很喜欢。我妈妈说这是我们家里她最喜欢的房间。哇！改造后的车库。上次我去你家时我参观了一下，这真的是一次相当大的蜕变。你们做得太棒了。我愿意睡在那里，亲爱的，我已经到了舒适睡眠对我很重要的年龄和人生阶段，所以它得到了我的认可。我太喜欢宜家关于如何打造完美睡眠的清单了。
I love for example that they mention sound in their list of sleep essentials because I actually sleep with a white noise machine in my bedroom. It's a huge part of my sleep strategy. My sister travels with one. Yeah. Yeah. And they also mention light. And I want to add to that lack of light as a sleep strategy because IKEA has great blackout curtains,
比如我很喜欢他们在睡眠要素清单中提到了声音，因为我睡觉时卧室里其实会开着一台白噪音机器。这是我睡眠策略中非常重要的一部分。我姐姐旅行时也会带一个。对。对。他们还提到了光线。我想把缺乏光线作为睡眠策略补充进去，因为宜家有极好的遮光窗帘，
which I have purchased and used before. I need a dark room to sleep. Yeah. I also sleep with a humidifier, which I think would fall under their essential air quality. I think so. Well, you can create your comfy blissful bedroom today with the IKEA 6 Sleep Essentials.
我以前买过并使用过。我需要一个黑暗的房间来睡觉。对。我还用加湿器睡觉，我觉得这应该属于他们列出的空气质量要素。我想是的。好吧，你可以用宜家的六大睡眠要素，在今天打造你舒适幸福的卧室。
Shop in store or online at ikea-usa.com slash sleep. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, in our life, we all have a support system. These are the people that help you get through the big life moments, the small life moments. They can be one of your favorite teachers or a coach, your mom or sister or best friend. It's so important to have that community because you know we're just all better when we have a support system behind us. And therapy can be a source of support
前往实体店或登录 ikea-usa.com/sleep 线上选购。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，在我们的生活中，我们都有一个支持系统。这些人帮助你度过生活中的重大时刻和微小时刻。他们可能是你最喜欢的老师或教练，你的妈妈、姐姐或最好的朋友。拥有这样一个社群是如此重要，因为你知道，当我们背后有一个支持系统时，我们所有人都会变得更好。而心理咨询可以成为你生活中任何领域的支持来源
for any area of your life. If it's time for you to shift focus or just put things in perspective, it's nice to know that there are people you can go to to ask for help. I know personally, I have such a strong support system that I lean on in the hard times that also celebrate with me in the good times,
。如果你是时候改变重心或者只是换个角度看待事物，很高兴知道有你可以求助、向其寻求帮助的人。我个人深有体会，我拥有如此强大坚实的支持系统，在艰难时刻我依靠他们，在美好时刻他们与我一同庆祝
and all the other little moments in between, and I'm so thankful for them. Build your support system with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash Office Ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. With the FIZ loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan. You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with FIZ.
，以及介于两者之间的所有其他小时刻，我非常感谢他们。使用 BetterHelp 建立你的支持系统。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com/OfficeLadies，你的第一个月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 BetterHelp，拼写是 H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。使用 FIZ 忠诚度计划，只要拥有移动套餐即可获得奖励。你知道的，就是发短信之类的。如果你的移动套餐没有获得诸如额外流量和现金折扣之类的奖励，说明你还没加入 FIZ。
Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at FIZ.ca. Welcome back everyone. So one of the things we did for All About Kevin Malone was to say our favorite Kevin moment. And I just loved that. So I thought me and Sam and Cassie could share our favorite Pam moment.
今天就切换吧。须遵守条件限制。详情请访问 FIZ.ca。欢迎回来，大家。我们在制作“凯文·马龙专场”时做的一件事，就是分享我们最喜欢的凯文高光时刻。我太喜欢那个环节了。所以我想我和萨姆、卡西可以分享我们最喜欢的帕姆时刻。
Sam, you wanna go first? Sure, I think mine out of, has to be from dinner party. It is this. I bet I can guess. It looks great, babe. Yeah, it really does. I know Jan didn't poison the food. I know that.
萨姆，你想先来吗？当然，我觉得我心中的最佳时刻，一定来自《晚宴派对》。就是这个。我敢说我能猜到。看起来真棒，宝贝。对，确实很不错。我知道简没有在食物里下毒。我知道这一点。
But if she was going to poison the food of someone at that table, wouldn't it be me? Michael's former lover. Either that or. Dinner sounded delicious. Pan, I'll see you at home. Thank you so much. Oh Jim, I don't think you're going to a pan in this party here all by itself. I don't know because everything I own is there. You can buy new stuff but you can't buy a new party.
但如果她真的要在座某人的食物里下毒，那难道不应该是我吗？迈克尔的前任情人。要么就是这个。晚餐听起来真美味。帕姆，回头在家见。非常感谢。哦，吉姆，我不觉得你会去一个只有帕姆一人在的派对。我不知道，因为我所有的东西都在那儿。你可以买新东西，但你买不到一个新派对。
That's true. That is a great point. Come on down here. Both of those, your delivery on them is just so great. Oh my gosh, thank you. I do love that. I also love from dinner party when Pam goes, I don't care what they say about me, I just want to eat. Oh my gosh, that gets played so often. I really, I felt that deeply.
没错。这话说得太对啦。快过来。这两个片段，你的台词表现力真的太棒了。哦天哪，谢谢。我确实很喜欢那个。我也很喜欢《晚宴派对》里的这一幕，当帕姆说：“我才不管别人怎么说我，我只想吃东西。”哦天哪，这个片段被播放得太频繁了。我真的，我对此感同身受。
Don't get you angry. I don't skip a meal. Cassie, what do you got? I feel like so many fans, it's when Pam discovers that Michael is dating her mom. Oh yes. But just the whole setup of like having that friend that's not good at dating and you wanna be supportive,
别惹你生气。我可从来不落下一顿饭。卡西，你准备了什么？我觉得很多粉丝的最爱，是帕姆发现迈克尔在和她妈妈约会的时候。哦，是的。但整个情境的设定，就是你有一个不擅长恋爱的朋友，你想支持她，
but then you find out in the worst way that absolutely not, you cannot date my mom. Pam, it is very complicated. There are a lot of moving parts here. Sounds complicated. Yeah, but I mean, if you really like this person, then you should see where it goes. You want me to be happy? Of course.
但接着你以最糟糕的方式发现，绝对不行，你绝对不能跟我妈约会。帕姆，这非常复杂。这里有很多动态因素。听起来很复杂。是的，不过，如果你真的喜欢这个人，那你应该看看发展到哪一步。你想让我幸福吗？当然。
Ugh. Part of the problem is she is the mother of a close friend of mine. Oh. More than a friend. A co-worker. Oh. Gossip. Who is it? Who is it? Who is it? Who is it? I love how into it she is. Yeah. I love the slow discovery. It's okay. Oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no nooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo But you know one that I always love, it always makes me smile. I just think it's such just a sweet moment and I thought your acting was so good in it. It's when Pam wins the Dundee for the whitest sneakers.
呃。问题的一部分在于，她是我的一个好朋友的母亲。哦。不仅仅是朋友。是个同事。哦。八卦。是谁？是谁？是谁？是谁？我太喜欢她那种全情投入的样子了。是的。我喜欢这种抽丝剥茧的发现过程。好吧。噢不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不，不过你知道我一直很喜欢哪一个吗，它总能让我会心一笑。我只是觉得这是一个无比温馨的时刻，而且我觉得你在那里的演技真的太棒了。就是帕姆赢得最白运动鞋邓迪奖的时候。
Aww. And this next award is going out to our own little Pam Beasley. I think we all know what award Pam is going to be getting this year. It is the whitest sneakers award because she always has the whitest tennis shoes on. Get on down here. Pam Beasley, ladies and gentlemen. Oh, here we go. I have so many people to thank for this award.
噢。接下来的这个奖项要颁给我们自己的小帕姆·比斯利。我想我们都知道今年帕姆会获得什么奖了。这就是最白运动鞋奖，因为她总是穿着最白的网球鞋。快上台来吧。女士们先生们，帕姆·比斯利。哦，来吧。我有太多人要感谢这个奖项了。
Okay, first off my kids, because I couldn't have done it without them. Thank you. Let's give Michael a round of applause for emceeing tonight because this is a lot harder than it looks. And also it's because of Dwight too. So, finally I want to thank God, because God gave me the stundy and I feel God in this chilies tonight.
好吧，首先是我的孩子们，因为没有他们我不可能做到这一点。谢谢。让我们为今晚担任司仪的迈克尔鼓掌，因为这比看起来要难得多。这也归功于德怀特。最后，我要感谢上帝，因为上帝赐予了我这个邓迪奖，今晚我在奇利餐厅（Chili's）感受到了上帝的存在。
That is such amazing dialogue. That was all written for me. It is so great. You just see her travel through all these different moments in her acceptance speech, kind of like when she finds out that Michael's dating her mom. I just saw, like, who you wanted to thank, but then you got back on track, but then you drifted off. You know, in researching all about Pam Beasley for this episode, I found out a piece of information and I considered withholding it.
这台词太绝了。这些都是为我写的。真的太棒了。你看着她在获奖感言中经历所有这些不同的情绪起伏，有点像她发现迈克尔在和她妈妈约会时的样子。我刚刚看到，就好像，你想感谢谁，但接着你又回到了正轨，但后来你又走神了。你知道的，在为本期节目研究所有关于帕姆·比斯利的内容时，我发现了一条信息，我曾考虑过要不要把它隐瞒下来。
What? But I'm gonna share it. You found out something about Pam Beasley and you weren't gonna tell us? Well. What? It's about whether or not Pam thinks the kiss at the Dundee's was their first kiss or not.
什么？但我还是决定分享出来。你发现了关于帕姆·比斯利的事情，而且你本来不打算告诉我们？好吧。什么？这关于帕姆认为在邓迪奖上的那个吻到底是不是他们的初吻。
What? What? What? I... Okay. Bracing. Bracing. And remember that pastor who said I was wrong? Mm-hmm. There's a deleted scene that was added to the Peacock superfan episode. Shut the front door.
什么？什么？我……好吧。做好心理准备。做好心理准备。还记得那个说我错了的牧师吗？嗯哼。有一个被删减的片段被加到了 Peacock 超级粉丝版剧集里。我的天哪。
Where Pam and Jim are that was added to the Peacock superfan episode. Shut the front door. Where Pam and Jim are talking about their lives and Jim brings up the kiss at the Dundee's. Yeah. Sort of says like, oh, but you were, I mean that you were kind of drunk. And Pam says, I know what I was doing. Ah! Ah!
帕姆和吉姆在那里……被加到了 Peacock 超级粉丝版剧集里。我的天哪。帕姆和吉姆在那里谈论他们的生活，吉姆提到了在邓迪奖上的那个吻。是的。有点像说，噢，不过当时你，我的意思是当时你有点喝醉了。帕姆说：我知道我在做什么！啊！啊！
Ah! Well, well, well. What episode is that in? Oh, let me look it up. Let's see. I found it. It's in launch party. Ha!
啊！好吧，好吧，好吧。那是哪一集？哦，让我查查。看看。我找到了。在《发布派对》里！哈！
Can we hear it? Oh man, is this a sweet moment for me. I knew today was gonna be a good day for you. I did not know it was gonna get this good for me. Oh no. I just found the clip. This is Pam and Jim up on the roof eating pizza. This is my moment.
能让我们听听吗？天哪，对我来说这真是个温馨的时刻。我知道今天对你来说会是个好日子。我可不知道对我来说能好到这种程度。哦，不。我刚找到那个片段。这是帕姆和吉姆在屋顶上吃披萨。这是我的时刻。
This is the super fan episode. I was a little buzzed, but I knew what I was doing. You looked so surprised. Yeah, I didn't know you were going to kiss me that night. One needs to prepare for these things. Oh my gosh! Wow. No, I'm sorry. I need to hear it again.
这是超级粉丝版。我当时是有点喝高了，但我知道我在做什么。你看起来太惊讶了。是啊，我不知道那天晚上你会亲我。面对这种事总得有点心理准备。噢天哪！哇。不，对不起。我需要再听一遍。
I need to hear it again. I need to hear it again. I was a little buzzed, but I knew what I was doing. You looked so surprised. Yeah, I didn't know you were gonna kiss me that night. One needs to prepare for these things. Oh! You look so surprised. I knew what I was doing.
我需要再听一遍。我需要再听一遍。我当时是有点喝高了，但我知道我在做什么。你看起来太惊讶了。是啊，我不知道那天晚上你会亲我。面对这种事总得有点心理准备。噢！你看起来太惊讶了。我知道我在做什么。
I knew what I was doing. Kudos to you for bringing that up, even though that defaults your entire argument. That's big of you. I wouldn't have brought it up. I just, I'm so happy. I feel seen. Oh, I knew it. I knew it, I knew it, I knew it.
我知道我在做什么。真佩服你把它提出来了，尽管这推翻了你的整个论点。你真大度。要是我才不会提呢。我只是，我太高兴了。我觉得自己被看见了。哦，我早就知道了。我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道。
Yeah. I feel like Kevin in that moment where he's like, can I finish? Can I finish? I knew it was their first kiss. It was. I concede. I can't believe you were gonna hold that back. I was gonna find it eventually, lady, and then I was gonna light you up. I know, and I had forgotten, but we did all these scenes up on the roof and were eating pizza and it was supposed to be kind of like a
是的。我感觉自己就像那个时刻的凯文，他当时说：我能说完吗？我能说完吗？我知道那是他们的初吻。确实是的。我认输。真不敢相信你刚才差点把这事瞒下来。亲爱的，我迟早会找到它的，然后我就会狠狠地戳穿你。我知道，我当时都忘了，但我们当时在屋顶上拍了所有这些吃披萨的戏，那本来应该是
throwback to when they ate the grilled cheese on the roof. Sure, sure, yeah. And we had all this dialogue where they wanted us to just reminisce about our relationship and I can't remember if that was improvised or if that was written. I don't remember. Well, guess who's gonna go to the shooting draft and see? You'll let us know. Launch party. I'm gonna look in the candy bags. Oh my gosh. Yep.
对他们在屋顶上吃烤奶酪那集的一个致敬。没错，没错，是的。我们有所有的台词，他们想要我们只是回忆一下我们的关系，我记不清那是即兴发挥还是写好的了。我不记得了。好吧，猜猜谁会去看拍摄剧本然后一探究竟？你会告诉我们的。《发布派对》。我要去糖果袋里找找看。天哪。没错。
Wowsers. Okay, I don't even know where we were. Oh, my other favorite Pam moment. The whole reason I'm wearing the shirt that says Pam Sass because I could not do an all about Pam Beasley and not talk about her PamSass. It's one of my favorite things. It is a runner throughout the entire series.
哇塞。好吧，我甚至不知道我们刚才聊到哪儿了。哦，我另一个最喜欢的帕姆时刻。我穿这件写着“帕姆毒舌”的T恤的全部原因，就是因为我做“帕姆·比斯利专场”不能不聊她的“帕姆毒舌”。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。这是贯穿整部剧的一个经典设定。
And we got a fan mail flurry about it. People really wanted us to share some PamSass. And guess what? As it turns out, there are a ton of PamSass video compilations online. There are so many. One of my favorites that I watched in prepping for this episode was titled,
我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝来信，都在聊这个。大家真的很想让我们分享一些“帕姆毒舌”。你猜怎么着？结果证明，网上有大量的“帕姆毒舌”高光混剪视频。真的有太多了。我在为本期节目做准备时看的最喜欢的其中一个视频标题是：
The Best of Pam's Brutal Comebacks. I mean, that's a great title. Here are just a few I'm going to play. I'm also going to read some. Let's start with Pam versus Kevin. Pam? When-hmm? When will the new copier be ready? I'm working on it, Kev.
《帕姆最精彩的毒舌回怼》。我是说，这标题太棒了。以下是我将要播放的几个片段。我也会朗读一些。让我们从帕姆对阵凯文开始。帕姆？嗯-哼？新复印件什么时候能准备好？我正在弄，凯文。
You said it would be ready by today, and it is today. It'll be ready soon. Soon could mean anything. Soon could be three weeks. Is that what soon means to you? Sometimes. Then come back soon. I mean, the sass.
你说过今天能准备好的，今天就是今天。很快就会准备好的。快可能意味着任何时间。快可能是三个星期。这就是你说的“快”的意思吗？有时。那你就快点回来。我是说，这毒舌。
That was pretty good. Is that what soon means to you? OK, now Pam versus Todd Packer. Don't ever let this little bitch drive you around town. We got a loss for a half an hour. I don't have any DUIs, so I can drive myself. But thanks. But thanks.
那挺精彩的。这就是你说的“快”的意思吗？好吧，现在是帕姆对阵托德·帕克（Todd Packer）。别让这个小碧池载着你在城里转悠。我们迟到了半个小时。我没有酒驾记录，所以我可以自己开车。不过还是谢谢你。不过谢谢。
That's kind of like Pam's bless your heart, but thanks. Yeah. Then there is the Halloween episode when Jim makes fun of her for believing in ghosts. And then Pam says she'll draw a picture of the ghost for Jim. And she just draws the middle finger and flips him off. That's right. But maybe the biggest category for Pam Sass,
这有点像帕姆版的“真为你感到难过，但谢谢啦”。是的。然后是万圣节那一集，吉姆因为帕姆相信有鬼而取笑她。然后帕姆说她要为吉姆画一张鬼的画。结果她画的只是一根中指，并向他竖中指。没错。但也许“帕姆毒舌”中最大的一类，
and honestly, this could be a whole show. Is it Pam versus Ryan? You betcha. It's my favorite. There are so many clips of Pam and Ryan going head to head. That's so great. It was really hard to choose. But you know what?
老实说，这可以单独做一期节目。是帕姆对阵瑞安吗？你猜对了。这是我的最爱。有太多帕姆和瑞安针锋相对的片段了。太棒了。真的很难抉择。但你知道吗？
This might be my favorite. Also, little tip, never shake the baby. Sorry, just to be clear, you're saying do not shake the baby? Don't shake the baby. A lot of times parents get frustrated because the baby's crying and they shake the baby and you gotta, you can't do that. Don't shake our baby? Yeah. Okay. I've never heard that before. So thank you. Yeah, I'm glad you said something. Me too. I'm glad you said something. Me too. I'm glad you said something. Oh, you guys, in our rewatch, I've shared this before.
这可能是我的最爱。还有，小贴士，千万不要摇晃婴儿。抱歉，为了明确起见，你的意思是不要摇晃婴儿？不要摇晃婴儿。很多时候父母会感到沮丧，因为婴儿在哭闹，然后他们就会摇晃婴儿，你得，你不能那样做。不要摇晃我们的婴儿？对。好吧。我以前从来没听过这个。所以谢谢。对，我很高兴你说了出来。我也是。我很高兴你说了出来。我也是。我很高兴你说了出来。哦，大家，在我们二刷时，我以前分享过这个。
I absolutely love Ryan. I love the way BJ Novak plays the character of Ryan. When I listen to that, his delivery is still so funny to me. We couldn't get through that scene. I mean, we busted up so many times. I watched so many Pam versus Ryan clips Last night and I really would love so much to just make it an episode and bring BJ in here because it is so wonderful That is the spin-off. I want to watch
我绝对爱死瑞安了。我太喜欢B·J·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）扮演瑞安这个角色的方式了。当我听那个时，他的台词表现力对我来说依然非常搞笑。我们根本无法拍完那场戏。我是说，我们笑场了太多次。我昨晚看了好多帕姆对阵瑞安的片段，我真的非常非常想把这做成一期节目，把B·J请到这里来，因为这太美妙了。这简直就是衍生剧。我想看
BJ Novak is one of my most favorite people ever. I would love that. And then there is Pam versus the entire Dunder Mifflin office. I'm gonna read this for you. It's from the Niagara episode when Pam was pregnant and she asked everyone in the office if they could kind of tone it down on the smelly stuff like Phyllis with her perfume soaps and Meredith and her cigars and then Dwight's super smelly lunches. She's having a really horrible morning sickness and she just said, can you guys just tone this down? Well, no one wants to change their routines. So Pam has a talking head where she says, I don't think I'm asking for too much. I guess it's just the end of courtesy in the workplace.
B·J·诺瓦克是我最喜欢的几个人之一。我会很乐意这样做的。然后是帕姆对阵整个邓德米夫林办公室。我要给你们读一段。这是来自《尼亚加拉大瀑布》那一集，当时帕姆怀孕了，她问办公室里的每个人能不能把那些有味道的东西稍微收敛一点，比如菲利斯的香皂、梅雷迪思的雪茄，还有德怀特超臭的午餐。她当时正经历可怕的晨吐，她只是说：你们能不能把这些稍微收敛一点？好吧，没有人想改变他们的日常习惯。于是帕姆有一个单采镜头，她说：我觉得我的要求并不过分。我猜这只是职场礼貌的终结。
And then it cuts to this scene. Dwight is peeling a hard-boiled egg at his desk. He sniffs it and takes a bite. Pam stares at him, picks up her trash can, and pukes in it. This causes a chain reaction. Andy, Phyllis, Meredith, Erin, Oscar, and Angela all proceed to throw up in various places in the office. Dwight stares shocked at Pam.
然后镜头切到这个场景。德怀特在办公桌前剥一个水煮蛋。他闻了闻，咬了一口。帕姆盯着他，拿起她的垃圾桶，在里面吐了。这引发了一连锁反应。安迪、菲利斯、梅雷迪思、艾琳、奥斯卡和安吉拉都开始在办公室的各个地方呕吐。德怀特震惊地盯着帕姆。
Pam wipes her mouth with a satisfied look. She took down the whole office. That's some Pam sass. And you know, I'm really barely scratching the surface. There's so much more Pam sass, but I wanna end with one of my all time favorites. It is Pam versus Dwight. It's one of the most stressful things you can do in life.
帕姆擦了擦嘴，露出一副满意的神情。她一个人搞垮了整个办公室。这就是“帕姆毒舌”。而且你知道，我真的只是触及了皮毛。还有更多超棒的“帕姆毒舌”，但我想要以我历来最喜欢的其中一个作为结尾。那是帕姆对阵德怀特。这是你在生活中能做的最具压力的事之一。
You'll probably just take it out on your kid. Jim will turn to the drink. The family will fall apart. And 25 years from now, Cece will become world famous for stripping. It's a sad story. I have another one. We move.
你很可能会把气撒在你的孩子身上。吉姆会借酒消愁。这个家庭会四分崩离析。25年后，西西（Cece）会因为脱衣舞而成名世界。这是一个悲伤的故事。我还有另一个。我们搬走。
The other tenants follow. The bank takes the building, takes your farm, takes your car and beats the crap out of you. Pennyless you die. And my daughter Cece dances on your grave, fully clothed. That's such a good speech. That's so good. My god, our writers are so good.
其他租户也跟着搬走。银行没收大楼，没收你的农场，没收你的车，把你痛打一顿。你身无分文地死去。而我的女儿西西在你的坟墓上跳舞，衣着齐整。这台词写得太棒了。太精彩了。天哪，我们的编剧太牛了。
It's such good writing. Oh my goodness. Well, that ends my Pam Sass segment of All About Pam Beasley. And now I wanna move on to this fan question from Fanola K in the UK. Which Pam moments are you proudest of? Well, when I think about The Office,
这剧本写得太好了。噢天哪。好吧，我的“帕姆毒舌”板块到此结束，这就是“帕姆·比斯利专场”。现在我想进入来自英国的费诺拉·K（Fanola K）的这个粉丝提问。你最引以为傲的帕姆时刻是哪几个？好吧，每当我回想起《办公室》，
I mean, I'm just so proud of the whole show and everything, but there is one moment that I am most proud of. And it is the talking head at the end of the job when Jim peeks his head in and asks Pam out on a date. Oh, and you tear up. I think it's one of my finest acting moments of my whole career frankly and I really credit Ken Quapus for getting that performance out of me. It was just I mean I don't even know how I did it. And you
我的意思是，我对整部剧和所有的一切都感到无比骄傲，但有一个时刻是我最引以为傲的。那就是求职那一集快结束时的单采镜头，当时吉姆探过头来问帕姆要不要一起去约会。哦，你都要哭了。坦白说，我认为这是我整个职业生涯中最好的演技时刻之一，我真的非常感谢肯·夸帕斯（Ken Quapus）激发出了我的这种表演。那简直是……我的意思是，我甚至不知道我是怎么做到的。你知道的，
know just as an audience just someone it, because now I'm watching it just as a fan of the show, that moment is so pivotal and meaningful. And you did it perfect, like perfect. It's so raw. And it really could only occur like if you gave me that scene in a movie, and I had to just do that, I don't know if I could have done it. But because I had the history of her story of years of playing this character and I had that relationship with Ken Quapus and so much of my reaction was from locking eyes with him and what he was giving me on the other side of the camera. Yeah. It was that look that like your dad gives you when he's proud of you. Oh.
作为一个观众，仅仅作为一个普通人看着它，因为现在我只是作为该剧的粉丝在看，那个时刻是如此关键且意义重大。而且你演得太完美了，简直完美。它是如此真实生动。这真的只有在那种情况下才能发生，如果你在一部电影里给我那个场景，让我直接去演，我不知道我是否能做到。但因为我拥有这个角色的多年历史背景，我了解这个角色的故事，而且我和肯·夸帕斯之间有那种默契，我的很大一部分反应来自于与他对视，以及他在摄像机镜头另一端给予我的东西。是的。那种眼神就像你爸爸为你感到骄傲时看着你的眼神。哦。
And it just melted me. So there were all of these circumstances that led to that moment happening. And I love that we captured it. And I love that it was Ken in that moment with you because he had been there since the very beginning. Yes. That's so important.
那一刻彻底融化了我。所以所有这些机缘巧合促成了那一刻的发生。我太喜欢我们捕捉到了这一幕。我太喜欢当时是肯陪着你经历那个时刻了，因为他从一开始就在那里。是的。这太重要了。
He was as invested in my character story as I was. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I love that moment too. Well, lady, now it's my turn to do some sharing. Well, we've started this tradition of each sharing an area of interest about our character. You know I love to title things, create structure.
他对我的角色故事的投入程度和我一样深。是的。是的。哦，我也超喜欢那个时刻。好吧，亲爱的，现在轮到我来分享了。好吧，我们已经开始了一个传统，那就是各自分享一个关于我们自己角色的兴趣领域。你知道我喜欢给事情起标题、建立结构。
I know. I love like our different ways of titling things. I'm like, Pam Sass, you're like area of interest. Yes. Well, for my Pam Beasley area of interest, I really tried to think of things that I hadn't already shared on the podcast. I mean, we've already shared on the podcast. I mean, we've broken down all the episodes.
我知道。我喜欢我们不同的起标题方式。我管它叫“帕姆毒舌”，你管它叫“兴趣领域”。是的。好吧，对于我的帕姆·比斯利兴趣领域，我真的尝试去思考一些我还没有在播客里分享过的事情。我的意思是，我们已经在播客里分享过了。我的意思是，我们已经把所有的剧集都拆解过了。
Yeah. I was really worried that I wouldn't have anything new to say. Like that the first kiss was at the Dundee's? Because I thought that was a pretty good one. Why are you being so hard on yourself? Okay. Okay. What else you got?
是的。我真的很担心我会没什么新东西可说。就像觉得初吻是在邓迪奖上那个算吗？因为我以为那算是一个相当不错的料。你干嘛对自己要求这么严苛？好吧。好吧。你还有什么？
Well, I thought of two things that I could share about playing Pam Beasley. Both of the things are two things that I could share about playing Pam Beasley. Both of the things are actor prep that I did. So the first thing is that when I'm prepping for a character, I sometimes go out in the world as that character. Like I'll go grocery shopping or I'll do other tasks pretending to be in character. Lady, you're so method. What if your character was like a bank robber? You can't go out in the world as the bank robber. But you can because my character won't be robbing a bank
好吧，我想到了两件关于扮演帕姆·比斯利可以分享的事情。这两件事都是关于扮演帕姆·比斯利的事。这两件事都是我做的演员准备工作。所以第一件事是，当我为一个角色做准备时，我有时会以那个角色的身份去现实世界中体验。比如我会假装成角色去杂货店购物或做其他事情。亲爱的，你太体验派了。如果你的角色是个银行劫匪呢？你总不能以银行劫匪的身份去现实世界吧。但你可以，因为我的角色又不会一直
the whole time. It'll just be a bank robber running errands. Yes. OK. Yes. So who am I when I go to the grocery store? Or how do I interact with the world? So I went to the grocery store as Pam.
在抢银行。她只会是一个去跑腿的银行劫匪。是的。好吧。是的。所以当我走进杂货店时我是谁？或者我是如何与世界互动的？于是我以帕姆的身份去了杂货店。
And I remember this very clearly. I was in line with my groceries and someone cut in front of me. How do you think Jenna feels about that? Oh, Jenna would be like, excuse me, I'm standing here. I would, I would say the end of the line is back there. Excuse me. Yeah, you'd be very fair, but you would let them know.
我对此记忆犹新。我拿着杂货排队，结果有人插队在我前面。你觉得珍娜对此会有什么感觉？哦，珍娜会说：不好意思，我站在这儿呢。我会的，我会说：队尾在后面呢。不好意思。是的，你会非常公平，但你会让他们知道的。
Correct. Yes. Well, Pam doesn't say anything apparently. I was Pam and she just let this person cut in front of her. Right. Yeah. It was just an interesting thing. So it's like, how do you find out little details about how your character reacts and interacts in the world, which I thought was important
没错。是的。好吧，帕姆显然什么都没说。我当时是帕姆，她就任由这个人插队到了她前面。对。是的。这真是一件有趣的事。所以这就好比，你如何去发现一些关于你的角色在现实世界中如何反应和互动的微小细节，我觉得这很重要，
because I knew that our show was going to have improvisation. Mm-hmm. And so I wanted to basically go out in the world and have people throw scenarios at me and see how Pam might react. And it's just information. I just love this. This is so thorough of you. I love it. I have to say one thing, one thing really quickly, which is one time I was standing in line for a movie and this lady cut in front of like legit cut in front. So much so that the girl taking the tickets like looked at me and then looked at her like the line forms here, you know? Yeah. And she looked at me and the lady goes, what? I'm going to my movie. Like, what's the deal?
因为我知道我们的节目会有即兴发挥。嗯哼。所以我基本上想去现实世界中，让人们抛给我各种场景，看看帕姆可能会作何反应。这全都是素材。我太喜欢了。你做得太彻底了。我爱死了。我必须说一件事，非常快速地说一件事，那就是有一次我排队看电影，有个女士插队，简直是名正言顺地插队。以至于卖票的女孩先看了看我，又看了看她，那眼神仿佛在说：队伍是从这里开始的，你知道吗？是的。然后她看着我，那位女士说：怎么了？我要去看我的电影。就这态度？
And I said to her, look, you cut in front of everyone, but clearly this is really important to you. Like, you need to get to this movie. And it's not important to me. So why don't you go to your movie? She was like mouth agape. Yeah. That's how you handle those line cutters.
我对她说：听着，你插了所有人的队，但显然这对你非常重要。比如，你需要看这场电影。而这对我并不重要。所以你为什么不去看你的电影呢？她当时听得目瞪口呆。是的。这才是对付那些插队者的方法。
I just shamed them. Exactly. I'm like matter of fact information, the end of the line is back there, polite about it, but you know. Yeah. You're like, shame. Shame.
我直接羞辱了他们。没错。我就像陈述事实一样：队尾在后面呢。态度很礼貌，但你知道的。是的。你就好像在说：真羞耻。真羞耻。
Clearly this is super important to you, so why don't you have it? We're going to let you have it. Well, interestingly enough, I also went to the movies as Pam. You did? Yes, I did. What did Pam go to see?
显然这对手超级重要，所以你为什么不去看呢？我们决定成全你。好吧，有趣的是，我也曾以帕姆的身份去看过电影。你真的去过？是的，我去过。帕姆去看什么了？
I don't remember what she went to see, but I have a very distinct memory that when she went up to get her snacks, my snack of choice is Diet Coke and Junior Mints. Is it really? Mm-hmm. That's what I would always get at the movies. Pam ordered a Diet 7-Up and popcorn. How come? Don't know. She loves Diet 7-Up apparently. So I did this
我不记得她去看什么了，但我有一个非常清晰的记忆，那就是当她去买零食时，我首选的零食是健怡可乐（Diet Coke）和迷你薄荷糖（Junior Mints）。真的吗？嗯哼。我以前在电影院总是买这个。帕姆点了一杯健怡七喜（Diet 7-Up）和爆米花。为什么？不知道。她显然很喜欢健怡七喜。所以我做了这个
exercise before I even auditioned for Pam and when I went to my audition I drank a Diet 7-Up. This is so wild to me. I did not know this. All these years I've known you, and I did not know that you made the choice that Pam drinks Diet 7 Up. Yeah, she does. She loves it. Wow. OK. All right.
练习是在我为帕姆试镜之前，当我区参加试镜时，我喝了一杯健怡七喜。这对我来说太疯狂了。我以前都不知道。认识你这么多年了，我竟然不知道你为帕姆做出了“她喜欢喝健怡七喜”这个角色设定。是的，她确实喜欢。她超爱这个。哇。好吧。好吧。
Here's the other thing I'm going to share. This is my other actor prep. When I am working on a character, a lot of times I will create a song list. We all know I made Sounds of Scranton. That was when we were doing the pilot. Well, in between season two and three, I made Pam songs. That's what I called my playlist, Pam songs.
还有一件事我要分享。这是我的另一个演员准备工作。当我正在塑造一个角色时，很多时候我会创建一个歌单。大家都知道我制作过《斯克兰顿之声》（Sounds of Scranton）。那是我们在拍试播集的时候。好吧，在第二季和第三季之间，我制作了“帕姆之歌”。那就是我给我的播放列表起的名字，“帕姆之歌”。
Please tell me you're gonna share your Pam songs. I'm gonna share my Pam songs. So on my Instagram lately, I've been sharing guitar riffs because I'm working on a song list for the character that I'm gonna play in Lee's movie. Right, Jodie. Right. And a lot of people asked if I would be willing to share
请告诉我你会分享你的“帕姆之歌”。我要分享我的“帕姆之歌”。所以最近在我的Instagram上，我一直在分享吉他弹奏，因为我正在为要在李的电影中扮演的角色制作一个歌单。对，乔迪（Jodie）。对。很多人问我是否愿意分享
my Pam song list, so I'm gonna do it today. Now, just to be clear, sometimes songs make the list because of their lyrics, sometimes it's just the vibe of the music, sometimes there's just the vibe of the music. Sometimes there's an even more specific reason. So here we go. First song on the list is Phone Call Number 27 by Admiral Twin. There's like a phone that rings at the beginning of the song. Oh! So it's like, you know, because Pam's gonna be answering phones. That's right. Okay. The next song is One by Amy Mann, then 50 Ways to Leave Your Lover by Paul Simon.
我的帕姆歌曲列表，所以我今天就要把它分享出来。话说清楚一点，有些歌入选是因为歌词，有些纯粹是因为音乐的氛围，还有些是因为音乐本身的意境。有时原因甚至更具体。所以我们要开始了。列表中的第一首歌是Admiral Twin乐队的《Phone Call Number 27》。歌曲开头有个电话铃声。哦！所以，你知道的，因为帕姆要接电话。没毛病。好啦。下一首歌是艾米·曼（Amy Mann）的《One》，然后是保罗·西蒙（Paul Simon）的《50 Ways to Leave Your Lover》。
Because she wants to leave Roy. Maybe. Maybe. Remember, I made this for between seasons two and three. So this is after Jim has, you know, confessed his love at casino night and then she's going to come back from the summer. So I was trying to create a vibe for her. The next is called Another First Kiss from They Might Be Giants. Because she knew she already had her first kiss and now she wants another first kiss.
因为她想甩了罗伊。也许吧。也许吧。记住，这个列表是我在第二季和第三季之间制作的。所以这是在吉姆（你知道的）在赌场之夜表白之后，她从夏天回来的时候。所以我当时在为她营造一种氛围。下一首是They Might Be Giants乐队的《Another First Kiss》。因为她知道自己已经有过初吻了，而现在她想要另一个初吻。
I'm gonna eat off that for a long time, so buckle in. And then the song, Please, Please, Please, Let Me Get What I Want by the Deftones. And I have an audio clip of this. So do you remember the episode in season three? It was back from vacation, and it's the one where Pam breaks down crying in the hallway and Dwight comes to comfort her?
这够我津津乐道好一阵子了，所以都系好安全带吧。接着是Deftones乐队的《Please, Please, Please, Let Me Get What I Want》。我有一段这段音乐的音频片段。大家还记得第三季里的那一集吗？那是她度假回来后，帕姆在走廊里崩溃大哭，然后德怀特去安慰她的那一集？
Yeah. I shared when we broke down that episode that in order to cry, I listened to music. This is the song I listened to on repeat in order to cry in that scene. And here's a clip. Okay, that's it. Lord knows it would be the first time. Okay, that's it. It's like, that song would not make me cry. It's that phrase, please, please, please, let me get what I want.
记得。当我们在回顾那一集时我分享过，为了能哭出来，我会听音乐。这就是我在那一幕中为了哭出来而单曲循环的歌。这是其中的一个片段。好吧，就到这儿。苍天作证，这还是头一次。好吧，就到这儿。我是说，这首歌根本不会让我哭。就是那句歌词，“请，请，请，让我如愿以偿吧”。
Lord knows it would be the first time. It's so visceral. That is, yeah. And just like, I hear the pain in the song and it just like triggered me. Yeah. So that song is only like two minutes long and I just listened to it on a loop. Yeah. And yeah.
苍天作证，这还是头一次。那种感觉太揪心了。确实，就是这样。而且，我能听出歌里的痛苦，它一下子触动了我。是的。所以这首歌只有大约两分钟长，我一直在单曲循环它。没错。然后呢，对。
Okay. So that song was on my playlist. I did an acting exercise when I was studying years ago and we did all pick a song. And then we let that song kind of take us to a place. And then we delivered a monologue. So when we do All About Angela Martin, I'll share my song. That helps me kind of get to a place where I break down. All right. OK.
好啦。所以这首歌在我的播放列表里。我多年前学习表演时做过一个练习，我们都选了一首歌。然后我们让这首歌把我们带入某种情绪中。接着我们发表了一段独白。所以，等我们做“安吉拉·马丁专集”时，我也来分享我的这首歌。这能帮我进入那种情绪崩溃的状态。好吧。行。
All right, the next song on my list is Come Away With Me by Nora Jones. And then the song NYC by Interpol. So this song is on the list because this is the song that John and I listened to in the parking lot during season two, The Client. So in the episode, you hear a different song. You hear Sing by Travis.
好啦，我列表里的下一首歌是诺拉·琼斯（Nora Jones）的《Come Away With Me》。然后是Interpol乐队的《NYC》。这首歌之所以上榜，是因为在第二季《客户》那一集里，我和约翰在停车场听的就是这首歌。所以在正片里，你听到的是另一首歌。你听到的是崔维斯（Travis）乐队的《Sing》。
That's not what we were actually listening to. We were listening to John's actual iPod, and this was a song. On one of his playlists? Yes. And he was like, oh, here's a good one. So this is the song we were listening to. I have an audio clip. The pavements, they are a mess
那并不是我们当时在听的歌。我们当时听的是约翰自己的iPod，而这首歌在里面。在他的某个播放列表里？对。然后他说，哦，这首挺不错。所以这就是我们当时在听的歌。我有一段音频剪辑。路面，它们一团糟
I know you've supported me for a long time But somehow I'm not impressed The New York kids Okay, so... That's a good piece of trivia. Yeah, that's what song that you were listening to. Yes, that's what we were swaying to in the parking lot. And I would like to thank John Krasinski because I could not remember what the song was.
我知道你支持了我很久 但不知怎么的我并没有被打动 纽约的这群年轻人 好了，所以…… 这是个不错的冷知识。没错，这就是你们当时在听的歌。对，这就是我们在停车场随着摇摆的音乐。我要感谢约翰·卡拉辛斯基，因为我记不清那是哪首歌了。
So I texted him and he remembered. And as soon as I turned it on, it was like a time machine. I heard that and I was like transported back in time to shooting that scene. It was so wild. Yeah. Music does that. It's really powerful. It does. Okay, so here's the rest of my list. Somewhere Only We Know by Keen, Cruel to Be Kind by Nick Lowe, Somebody to Love by Queen, Through Any Window by Willie Wisely, Danny Says by The Ramones, Our Love by Rhett Miller, and One Down by Ben Folds. And I don't know, can you share playlists?
所以我发信息问他，他想起来了。我一放这首歌，感觉就像坐上了时间机器。我一听到它，就像被传送回了拍摄那一幕的过去。太神奇了。对啊。音乐就是有这种魔力。真的很震撼。确实如此。好吧，我的列表剩下的还有这些：《Somewhere Only We Know》by Keen，《Cruel to Be Kind》by Nick Lowe，《Somebody to Love》by Queen，《Through Any Window》by Willie Wisely，《Danny Says》by The Ramones，《Our Love》by Rhett Miller，还有《One Down》by Ben Folds。话说，你们能分享播放列表吗？
Yeah, you can. Listen to me, here's the funny thing. You guys, I do not make playlists in my real life as Jenna. I don't make, I just don't. I listen to podcasts, I don't listen to music, but weirdly, when I am playing a character, they they get a song list and music is a huge way into character for me If you make it on Spotify and make it public you can share it. I'll do that. There you go Well, I can share with everyone. I have road tripped with you and there is no music
当然可以。听我说，有趣的是。各位，我在现实生活中作为詹娜根本不制作播放列表。我不会做，我就是不弄。我听播客，不听音乐，但奇怪的是，当我饰演一个角色时，他们就会拥有一个歌单，音乐对我来说是深入了解角色的一个重要途径。如果你在Spotify上制作并设为公开，你就可以分享它。我会这么做的。这就对了。好吧，我可以和大家分享。我和你一起自驾游过，你车上根本没有音乐。
There's no music if you have to play Jenna Fischer in a movie one day, your playlist is nothing. Silence. Your playlist is the news. That's what I listen to. I love your playlist, and I can't wait for us to share it. Up next is my Pam Beasley area of interest, and I'm tackling a fan theory here.
根本没有音乐。如果你有一天要在电影里扮演詹娜·费舍，你的播放列表就是一片空白。一片寂静。你的播放列表就是新闻。那就是我听的。我很喜欢你的播放列表，等不及要我们把它分享出来了。接下来是我的“帕姆·比斯利兴趣区”，我要在这里探讨一个粉丝理论。
The fan theory is that Pam is the one that the documentary crew was following all along. I just thought that this was such an interesting take on the whole show, and I have a few things to support it, okay? Okay. So this theory says that the entire show is actually centered around Pam's perspectives and experiences, and that the camera crew was interested particularly in her life and showing her life as it evolved through the series, and that the show is not a documentary about a paper company. You know, a lot of the other characters have relationships as the years go on, but Pam is the one that develops close
这个粉丝理论是，帕姆其实才是纪录片摄制组从头到尾一直在跟拍的人。我只是觉得对整部剧来说，这是一个非常有趣的切入点，我有一些证据来支持它，好吗？好。所以这个理论认为，整部剧实际上是以帕姆的视角和经历为中心的，摄像团队对她的生活以及展示她的人生在剧集中的演变过程特别感兴趣，而且这部剧并不是一部关于一家造纸公司的纪录片。你知道的，随着时间的推移，其他许多角色也有过恋爱关系，但帕姆才是那个建立起亲密
friendships with people. She is the only character throughout the show that connects with people in one way or another. And you can see it if you watch the show. She's there for Dwight when Dwight needs her. She's there for Angela when Angela is crying about sprinkles. She's there for Michael over and over. She's like his support system. She is there for Kelly when Kelly is worried
友谊的人。在整部剧中，她是唯一一个能以这样或那样的方式与人们建立联系的角色。如果你看剧的话就能发现。德怀特需要时，她一直在德怀特身边。安吉拉为小不点（猫）哭泣时，她在安吉拉身边。她一次又一次地陪伴迈克尔。她就像是他的后盾。凯莉担心
about Ryan cheating on her. She's there for Nellie. She was there for Kelly when Kelly is worried about Ryan cheating on her. She's there for Nellie. She was there for Meredith. They go and like do karaoke together. She has moments with Oscar and Toby in the Finders Things Club. And obviously, she's there for Jim. But if you watch the show with Pam as the main focus, it really opens up all of these moments. But if you watch the show with Pam as the main focus, it really opens up all of these moments.
瑞安对她不忠时，她在凯莉身边。她在内莉身边。凯莉担心瑞安对她不忠时，她在凯莉身边。她在内莉身边。她在梅雷迪思身边。她们一起去唱卡拉OK。她和奥斯卡、托比在“寻物俱乐部”里也有过互动。当然，她一直陪着吉姆。但是，如果你以帕姆为核心来看这部剧，它真的会让你对所有这些时刻有全新的理解。但是，如果你以帕姆为核心来看这部剧，它真的会让你对所有这些时刻有全新的理解。
You really see how Pam was the person people went to talk to. I believe that, yeah, that tracks for me. I'm not sure if that means the documentary was about her. I wanna hear more. Okay, so number one, Pam is the emotional support for everyone. She is the person people can fight in. Number two, Pam's presence lives on. After the documentary is over, she is the one character that has a physical lasting mark on the Dunder Mifflin workplace. In the last season, Pam decides to create the mural in the Dunder Mifflin workplace. In the last season Pam decides to create the mural in the
你真的会发现，帕姆就是大家遇到事情时会去找的那个人。我相信这一点，是的，这说得通。我不确定这是否意味着纪录片就是关于她的。我想听更多。好，那么第一点，帕姆是每个人的情感支柱。她是大家可以倾诉的人。第二点，帕姆的存在感一直延续了下去。纪录片结束后，她是唯一一个在邓德米夫林工作场所留下了实体长久印记的角色。在最后一季中，帕姆决定在邓德米夫林的
Dunder Mifflin warehouse. She draws all of the characters from the show and Pam is the only person in the series who when she actually physically leaves Dunder Mifflin leaves something behind her legacy her mark. Okay. Well you know well we'll see this is a fan theory. Okay. No one else paints a whole wall. True. True. I mean, Dwight does own the business park, but still he hasn't left a huge piece of artwork forever saying, I was here. True. Number three is inspired by Keely C from Mexico who wrote in to say, I have a theory about the documentary crew and it is that it favors Pam over everyone else in the office and that she
仓库里创作一幅壁画。她画了剧中所有的角色，而帕姆是剧中唯一一个当她真正离开邓德米夫林时，留下了某些东西——她的传奇，她的印记——的人。好吧。嗯，你知道，我们走着瞧，这只是个粉丝理论。好吧。没有其他人画整面墙。确实。确实。我是说，德怀特确实拥有那个商业园区，但即便如此，他也没有留下巨大的艺术作品，永远地诉说“我来过这里”。确实。第三点是由来自墨西哥的基莉·C（Keely C）启发而来的，她写信说：“我有一个关于纪录片摄制组的理论，那就是相比办公室里的其他人，他们更偏爱帕姆，她是他们最喜欢的主题。”
was their favorite subject. She goes on to say she thinks that they interview Pam more than the other characters. She believes that the documentary crew was always rooting for Pam. Do you believe this theory? First of all, Keely, I found an article online that agrees with you on CBR.com. It says, Pam is the only character who really changes throughout the years. Pam starts as an insecure, timid, self-effacing young woman and ends the series as an assertive professional who establishes boundaries both in her professional and personal life.
她接着说，她认为摄制组采访帕姆的次数比其他角色都多。她坚信纪录片摄制组一直都在支持帕姆。你相信这个理论吗？首先，基莉，我在CBR.com上找到了一篇文章，上面的观点和你不谋而合。文章说：“帕姆是剧中唯一一个随着岁月真正发生改变的角色。帕姆以一个缺乏自信、胆小、妄自菲薄的年轻女性开始，以一个自信的专业人士结束了整部剧，她在职业和个人生活中都树立了边界感。”
And finally, the same article said the following, and Jenna, I know that you and Brian talked about this on his podcast, The Deep Dive, but it suggests that Pam, having the last line of the series, proves all of this, and here's what the article said. The office ends with a tearful sequence featuring several interviews of the characters mixed with emotional and sometimes hilarious scenes. However, Pam's interview is the last one to appear in the mockumentary, which leaves the audience with the feeling that Pam is the one saying goodbye. Pam says there's a lot of beauty in ordinary things, isn't that kind of the point? Which wraps up the idea of following the supposedly ordinary and uneventful life of people working at an office. But the fact that Pam has the last line in the show and she sums up the premise
最后，同一篇文章还写了这样一段，詹娜，我知道你和布莱恩在他的播客节目《深入探讨》（The Deep Dive）中讨论过这个，但它表明，帕姆拥有全剧的最后一台词证明了这一切，文章是这样写的。办公室以一个充满泪点的片段结束，其中穿插了对各个角色的多次采访，并夹杂着感人甚至搞笑的场景。然而，帕姆的采访是伪纪录片中最后一个出现的，这给观众留下了帕姆是那个在说再见的人的感觉。帕姆说：“平常的事物中也有很多美，这难道不是意义所在吗？”这就呼应了追踪办公室里那些本该平常且平淡无奇的人的生活这一核心理念。但帕姆拥有剧中的最后一台词并且由她总结了本剧的
of the series adds up to Pam being the office's main character. What are your thoughts? Well, I remember talking to Greg about this when I saw that I had the last talking head. I was so honored and nervous. And he said that he always kind of thought the documentary crew was following Pam, that that was true. I mean, yeah, because I honestly never thought it was about Michael. I thought because Michael was the boss, he maybe got more screen time because he could manufacture those moments more easily. Well, you know, the documentary doesn't stop when Michael leaves. Yeah. And a number of people leave in season nine as well. And the documentary doesn't stop when Michael leaves. And a number of people leave in season nine as well,
核心前提，这一事实恰恰证明了帕姆就是办公室的主角。你有什么看法？嗯，当我看到自己拥有最后一个面对镜头的独白时，我记得我和格雷格谈过这件事。我感到非常荣幸又紧张。他说他其实一直觉得纪录片摄制组就是在跟拍帕姆，这是真的。我是说，是的，因为老实说，我从来不觉得它是关于迈克尔的。我以为因为迈克尔是老板，他可能得到了更多的出场时间，因为他能更轻易地制造出那些戏剧效果。嗯，你知道，纪录片在迈克尔离开后并没有停止。是的，而且在第九季中也有一些人离开了。纪录片在迈克尔离开后并没有停止，
and the documentary doesn't stop when they leave either. You know, Andy goes off and it doesn't follow him. Right, Kevin. Yep, exactly. And you know, the documentary crew does capture a lot of private moments for Jim and Pam. They do follow Pam out of the office quite a bit. I mean, the cameras are there for the birth of the baby.
而且在他们离开后，纪录片也没有停止。你知道的，安迪走了，但镜头并没有跟着他。没错，凯文也是。没错，确实如此。而且你知道，纪录片摄制组确实捕捉到了吉姆和帕姆的许多私密时刻。他们确实跟着帕姆离开了办公室好多次。我是说，宝宝出生时摄像机就在现场。
The cameras are there for the proposal, for the wedding. I mean, I know they went to these personal events for other people too. When Pam found out she was pregnant, they were there. Yeah, but I do have one piece of evidence that I think contradicts this theory, which is that they don't really show much of her at art school. And that's kind of a big thing for her to have done. And they don't show much
求婚时、婚礼时摄像机都在。我是说，我知道他们也去参加了其他人的这些个人活动。帕姆发现自己怀孕时，他们在场。是的，但我确实有一个证据，我认为它与这个理论相矛盾，那就是他们在艺术学校时并没有怎么展现她。对她做过的事情来说，这算是一件大事了。而且他们也没有表现出对她太多的
interest in her. So I believe that this documentary really was about a paper company. I think that is what is the main subject about the lives of people in a paper company. But I do also think that Pam was a main subject of interest. Yeah. I mean, here's my take. I agree with you. I think it was a documentary about an everyday small company and just what it's like to work in a small company. But I think what happens, and we know this to be true, especially if you sit down and talk to Dave Rogers, which is there is one story that you film,
兴趣。所以我相信这部纪录片其实是关于一家造纸公司的。我认为这才是主要主题，关于一家造纸公司里人们的生活。但我也确实认为帕姆是一个核心关注对象。是的。我是说，我的看法是这样的。我同意你的观点。我认为这是一部关于一个日常小公司的纪录片，讲述在小公司工作是什么感觉。但我认为发生的事情是——我们知道这是真的，特别是当你坐下来和戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）交谈时，那就是：你拍摄的是一个故事，
and there's another story that you find. So I think the documentary crew filmed all of this footage. And then when they sat down to edit it, that's when the story took shape. And they saw all this footage of Jim and Pam, and they became enamored with showing their story. And that's why so much of Jim and Pam is in it. So I think the editor found Pam.
而你剪辑出来的是另一个故事。所以我觉得纪录片摄制组拍摄了所有这些素材。然后当他们坐下来剪辑时，故事才真正成形。他们看到了所有关于吉姆和帕姆的素材，然后就迷上了展现他们的故事。这就是为什么吉姆和帕姆的内容占了那么多。所以我觉得是剪辑师“发现了”帕姆。
And maybe that's someone I'd love to meet who edited the documentary. Yeah. Because whoever did had a soft spot for Pam. I think that's true. Well there you go. Well I loved your area of interest. Should we take a break and then we're gonna come back and you've got a Q&A for me Angela. I do. So many people wrote in questions for you about Pam and I just love our office ladies listeners. They send in the
也许那是我很想见的人，剪辑这部纪录片的人。是的。因为无论谁剪的，对帕姆都有一种特殊的偏爱。我觉得是这样的。好吧，那就这样吧。我很喜欢你的兴趣区。我们要不要休息一下，然后回来，安吉拉，你为我准备了一个问答环节？没错。有好多人给你发了关于帕姆的问题，我太喜欢我们的“办公室女士”听众了。他们发来的
best questions they're so thoughtful and wonderful observations we'll get to those after the break. When the frustration grows and the doubts start to creep in we all need someone who has our back to tell us we'll be okay, to remind us of our ability to believe, because their belief in us transfers to self-belief and reminds us of all that we're capable of. We all need someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. someone to make us believe. Hashtag, you got this. This episode is brought to you by Samsung Galaxy. Ever captured a great night video only for it to be ruined by that one noisy talker? With audio erase on the new Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra, you can reduce or remove unwanted
都是最棒的问题，非常有深度，观察也很精彩，我们休息过后就会解答这些。当挫折感滋生、自我怀疑开始悄然潜入时，我们都需要一个坚强后盾，告诉我们一切都会好起来，唤醒我们内心坚定的信念，因为他们对我们的信任会转化为我们对自己的信心，并提醒我们自己拥有无限的可能。我们都需要有人让我们重拾信念。话题标签：你可以的。有人让我们重拾信念。话题标签：你可以的。本集由三星Galaxy赞助播出。你是否曾捕捉到一段精彩的夜景视频，却被旁边某个吵闹的说话声给毁了？有了全新三星Galaxy S25 Ultra上的音频橡皮擦功能，你可以降低或消除不必要的
noise and relive your favorite moments without the distractions. And that's not all. New Galaxy AI features like NowBrief will give you personalized insights based on your day schedule so that you're prepared no matter what. Buy the Samsung Galaxy S25 Ultra now at Samsung.com. We are back with our All About Pam Beasley episode and it is time for our fan Q&A. I'm kicking us off with Raquel C. from Michigan and Megan V. from Columbia.
噪音，尽情回味你最喜爱的时刻，不再受任何杂音干扰。不仅如此。全新的Galaxy AI功能，比如“今日简报”（NowBrief），会根据你的日程安排为你提供个性化的洞察，让你无论面对什么都能做好准备。立即前往Samsung.com购买三星Galaxy S25 Ultra。我们带着我们的“帕姆·比斯利专集”回归了，现在是我们的粉丝问答环节。我先从来自密歇根州的拉奎尔·C（Raquel C.）和来自哥伦比亚的梅根·V（Megan V.）的问题开始。
They wrote in and asked, where did the name Pam Beasley come from? And then also Joe H. from Long Island, New York says, were there ever any alternate firsts and last names for Pam? Well, here's what I can tell you. All of my scripts, my breakdown, everything from the beginning of me being part of this project, my name was Pam Beasley.
她们写信问：“帕姆·比斯利这个名字是怎么来的？”然后还有来自纽约长岛的乔·H（Joe H.）问：“帕姆的名字以前有没有过其他的备选名和姓？”好吧，我能告诉你们的是：我所有的剧本、人物设定，从我加入这个项目一开始，我的名字就是帕姆·比斯利。
Not Pamela. Nope. But I did reach out to Greg because he always has a good story for how he picked someone's name. Yeah. First of all, he confirmed that this character's name has only ever been Pam Beasley. There were no other alternates. But here is how he came to name her.
不是帕梅拉。没有。不过我确实联系了格雷格，因为他对如何给角色起名字总有说不完的好故事。是的。首先，他确认这个角色的名字一直都叫帕姆·比斯利。没有任何其他的备选名。但他是这样给她起名字的：
Pam to me has a Midwestern sweetness that felt right. And I liked how similar the Jim and Pam sounds are. Oh, then they're both three letters. As for Beasley, that came later. It has a humble feel, like generations ago. They were the village beekeeper who sold honey. Oh Greg. I love him. So that's how he came up with the name. I love it. Next question is from Lucy P in Tennessee. Lucy says, do you think Pam would have gone on a date with Toby if he ever asked her out in season four?
“对我觉得，帕姆有一种中西部式的甜美，感觉很对。而且我喜欢吉姆和帕姆这两个发音有多么相似。”哦，而且它们都是三个字母。至于比斯利，那是后来才想到的。它有一种朴实的感觉，就像几个世纪前，他们是村里卖蜂蜜的养蜂人一样。哦，格雷格。我太喜欢他了。这就是他起这个名字的由来。我太喜欢了。下一个问题来自田纳西州的露西·P（Lucy P.）。露西问：“你觉得如果在第四季中托比约过帕姆的话，帕姆会跟他约会吗？”
Or would she have turned him down? Lucy I Don't think she would have gone on a date with him and when she said in that game Who would you do and she said Oscar or Toby she was just saying that because she couldn't say Jim right. I don't think Pam ever saw Toby that way. I don't think so either. Yeah. But I love that question. Next up is Aaron S. from Maryland. Aaron says one of the best things the writers on the show did was not to have Jim and Pam get together right after season one.
还是说她会拒绝他？露西，我觉得她不会跟他约会的。当她在那个“你想跟谁酱酱酿酿”的游戏里说她选奥斯卡或托比时，她那么说只是因为她不能说吉姆，对吧。我觉得帕姆从来没把托比当过那种人看待。我也这么觉得。没错。但我很喜欢这个问题。接下来是来自马里兰州的亚伦·S（Aaron S.）。亚伦说：“剧里的编剧们做得最棒的事情之一，就是没有让吉姆和帕姆在第一季刚结束时就在一起。”
It's very subtle when you're just watching through the episodes, but it's so powerful that Pam was given the time to be on her own after ending her long engagement. On the initial watch, it feels like Pam is being silly or cowardly, not just telling Jim how she feels. But I actually think that was the much more difficult and much braver decision. Her personal growth during that period when Jim is away and then when he returns and dates Karen is so great to watch and re-watching when the initial frustration of prolonging the Jim and Pam's union is not so strong. Can you share any thoughts you have about Pam's growth
当你一路看下来时，这种处理非常微妙，但帕姆在结束了长期的订婚之后，能有时间去享受独处，这种力量是非常强大的。在刚开始看的时候，你会觉得帕姆很傻或者很懦弱，为什么不直接告诉吉姆她的感受。但其实我认为这是一个艰难得多、也勇敢得多的决定。她在吉姆离开的那段期间，以及后来吉姆回来、和凯伦约定时个人的成长，看起来真的很棒。而且重看时，那种急于看到吉姆和帕姆在一起的初始挫折感就没有那么强烈了。你能分享一下你对帕姆在这期间成长的看法，以及你在没有吉姆的戏份中，有哪些你最喜欢的剧情线吗？
during this time and some of your favorite storylines she had without Jim? Oh, Erin, I absolutely loved season three as Pam for this very reason. I loved season two, but I just love Pam figuring out who she is, away from Roy and away from Jim. I did too. I thought it was really important. Really important. And in answer to your question about just some of my favorite storylines that I had without Jim, because I think we do think of Jim and Pam together a lot, but there were
哦，亚伦，作为帕姆的我真的超爱第三季，正是因为这个原因。我很喜欢第二季，但我更喜欢帕姆去探索真正的自己，远离罗伊，也远离吉姆。我也是。我觉得这真的很重要。非常重要。至于你问到我有哪些没有吉姆的最喜欢的剧情线，因为我觉得大家确实经常把吉姆和帕姆联系在一起，但在我在办公室的这段时间里，确实有一些很棒的剧情线，是完全属于帕姆的，或者是帕姆和其他人的，然后……
great storylines throughout my time in the office that I got to have that were all for Pam or that were Pam and other people and... I know, I know one of my favorites. What is it? Michael Scott Paper Company. Yes, I actually pulled a fan question that I saw from Audrey D. in Lafayette, Louisiana. My birth town? Yes, who said, Hi ladies, I'm 15 and a huge fan. I was wondering, at what point in the show do you think Pam was at her happiest and most authentic? For me, it seems like the Michael Scott Paper Company
我知道，我知道我最喜欢的一个。是什么？迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。没错，我其实挑了一个粉丝问题，来自路易斯安那州拉斐尔的奥黛丽·D（Audrey D.）。我的出生地？是的，她说：“嗨，女士们，我15岁，是个超级粉丝。我想知道，你觉得在剧中的哪个阶段，帕姆是最快乐、最真实的？对我来说，好像是迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司
arc. She feels more regulated, silly, happy, and genuine, even though she's technically farther from Jim. Well, I have to agree with that too. And I liked that we had these moments on the show where we got to see Pam flourishing, separate from her love relationship. Yeah. And I made a list of a few others that I just loved getting to do on the show. My nothing to do with Jim storylines. Lice. Lice.
的那段剧情。她感觉更规律、更傻气、更快乐、也更纯粹，尽管从技术上讲她离吉姆更远了。”好吧，我也必须对此表示赞同。而且我很喜欢我们在剧中拥有这些时刻，能看到帕姆在她的恋爱关系之外独自绽放。是的。我还列出了一些其他我非常喜欢在剧中演出的剧情。我那些跟吉姆毫无关系的剧情线。长虱子。长虱子。
I mean, I guess it kind of has something to do with Jim, but it's really about Pam and Meredith. It is. And I loved it. Everything party planning committee, especially the dueling Christmas parties. Yes. I loved her relationship with Karen in that episode, them teaming up. Yeah. I watched all of our party planning committee scenes when I was researching Pam Sass. Mm-hmm. I wanted to play a bunch. But I already felt like I had a lot of Pam Sass. But oh man there's some good ones. Well I also loved Big Pregs Little Pregs. Yeah. I love my cold open with the chore wheel. Yes. And Pam's just like love of order and chores and things that spoke to me.
我是说，这大概也跟吉姆有点关系，但它其实是关于帕姆和梅雷迪思的。确实如此。而且我很喜欢它。还有各种派对策划委员会，尤其是双簧圣诞派对。是的。我很喜欢她在那一集里和凯伦的关系，她们组队合作。是的。当我研究“帕姆的毒舌”时，我把我所有的派对策划委员会的戏份都看了一遍。嗯哼。我想好好演一通。但我本来就觉得自己有很多帕姆式的毒舌。不过哦天哪，里面真的有很多精彩的桥段。嗯，我也很喜欢大肚帕姆和小肚帕姆。是的。我很喜欢我和值日轮盘的那场开场戏。是的。还有帕姆对秩序、杂务的热爱，以及那些能引发我共鸣的东西。
Yeah. And I loved the episode vandalism when she teams up with Dwight and they are like paint the truck and all that stuff. I just love that. And then I just, I loved every bit of her relationship to Michael, you know? Yeah.
对。我超喜欢《破坏公物》那一集，她和德怀特组队，他们去喷漆卡车之类的事情。我太爱那个了。然后还有，我喜欢她和迈克尔之间的每一段关系，你知道的？对。
And that was very separate from her relationship with Jim. It's so fun in doing these all about episodes because I feel like when I watch the show, I watched it for the whole ensemble, but in doing these all about, I go specifically to these scenes for this one character. Yeah. And I watched a lot of the Michael Scott Paper Company episodes and just Pam and Michael on the road together. Yeah. Is so good. It was so fun to do. Next question is from Matt V in Delaware. Matt says, while I truly love every aspect of the
这和她与吉姆的关系是完全分开的。做这些“专集”节目真的很有趣，因为我觉得当我观看这部剧时，我是为了整个演员阵容去看的，但在做这些专集时，我会专门为了这个单一角色去看这些场景。是的。我看了很多迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的剧集，仅仅是帕姆和迈克尔在路上的时光。是的。太精彩了。拍起来真的超级过瘾。下一个问题来自特拉华州的马特·V（Matt V.）。马特说：“虽然我真的喜欢办公室的方方面面，但唯一让我至今仍感到惊艳的，是帕姆看着吉姆的眼神，和看其他任何东西时的对比。”
office, the singular thing that consistently still blows me away is every time the way Pam looks at Jim compared to anything else. There is something just so incredibly natural and real about it." He goes on to say, "'Jenna, how did you tap into something that felt so genuinely real for these non-speaking portions of the role? Was there a crush from your childhood you were pulling back up the feelings from, or was it just through trying to truly feel what you believe Pam was feeling? Well, Matt, I appreciate this question
“那种眼神里有一种极其自然和真实的东西。”他接着问：“詹娜，对于这些非对白的角色部分，你是如何捕捉到那种感觉如此真实自然的呢？你是从童年时期的某段暗恋中重新调取了那种感觉，还是仅仅通过去真诚地感受你认为帕姆当时的感受来做到的？”好吧，马特，我很感激这个问题，
because a lot of the role of Pam Beasley is non-verbal. Yeah, it's a lot of reacting. Yes, and so I had to really say a lot without a lot of dialogue. So I went back to a couple of exercises that I did in acting school. One of them was called Private Moment and it's an exercise in stillness. You have to come to class and recreate an ordinary moment and try to do it in front of people as unselfconsciously as possible. It's supposed to be a moment
因为帕姆·比斯利这个角色的很大一部分都是非语言的。是的，有很多反应镜头。是的，所以我必须在没有太多台词的情况下表达很多东西。所以我回顾了几个我在表演学校做过的练习。其中一个叫做“私密时刻”，这是一个关于静止的练习。你必须来到课堂上，重现一个平常的时刻，并尽量在众人面前尽可能不带自我意识地把它表演出来。这应该是一个
in silence without any speaking and also something that you would normally do alone. But it should be very ordinary and very simple. So it could be as simple as putting on shoes in the morning or brushing your teeth or washing your face or sitting on your bed and writing in a journal. And you just have to move through that moment without trying to push it all. And without even thinking that anyone is watching you. It's that private quiet time when you're alone in your home. Yes, completely non-performative in any way. We also had to do these acting exercises called interior monologues. And this is where in your script you go through
在安静中、没有任何对话的时刻，而且也是你平时一个人会做的事情。但它应该非常平常、非常简单。所以它可以简单到早上穿鞋、刷牙、洗脸，或者坐在床上写日记。你只需要顺着那个时刻走下去，而不要去刻意推动它。甚至不需要去想有没有人在看你。那就是当你独自在家时那种私密而安静的时光。是的，在任何方面都完全不是表演性质的。我们还得做一种叫做“内心独白”的表演练习。这就是在剧本中，
and you write everything your character is thinking but not saying. And when I played Pam, I was always asking myself, what is Pam not saying? And we do this in our life all the time. We can sit in a work meeting and we're literally talking, but also making a grocery list in our head. You know, it's like we can think one thing
把你角色正在想但没有说出口的所有内容都写下来。当我饰演帕姆时，我总是问自己：帕姆没有说出口的是什么？我们在生活中也经常这样做。我们可以坐在一个工作会议上，我们在字面上说着话，但脑子里其实在列着购物清单。你知道的，就好像我们可以心里想着一件事，
and say another thing. So that was another thing I brought to Pam. And early on, I would write her interior monologues in my script and I would actively think them as if they were like alternate lines for my brain. And that's how I tried to get certain things to play out on my face when I didn't have dialogue. So like if there was a moment in the script
嘴上说另一件事。所以这也是我带给帕姆的另一个东西。在早期，我会在剧本里写下她的内心独白，我会在脑海中积极地去想它们，就好像它们是我大脑的备选台词一样。这就是我如何在没有台词的情况下，让某些情感在我的脸上展现出来的方法。所以，如果在剧本中有这样一个时刻，
where I was supposed to steal a glance at Jim, I would think to myself, don't look at Jim, don't look at Jim, don't look at Jim. And then I would look at him. And I would sort of hope that that would reveal how much Pam really wanted to look at him. Yeah. Because I would be thinking, don't look at him thinking don't look at him, don't look at him, yeah. Don't look at him. That's so good. I would write like one word next to like a
我需要偷瞄吉姆一眼，我就会在心里对自己说：“别看吉姆，别看吉姆，别看吉姆。”然后我就会看他。我其实是希望借此展现出帕姆到底有多么渴望看他一眼。对。因为我会一边想着“别看他”，一边想着“别看他，别看他，是的”。别看他。太棒了。我会在旁边写下一个词……
paragraph if I had dialogue, whatever it might be that I thought Angela was feeling down deep about something because she often was just so kind of hostile and abrupt. But maybe that day she was feeling fearful or sad or anxious. So I would just write an emotion word to go along with what was being said. Which is why I think your character was so layered rather than that one note of bitchiness. You always had your secondary emotion that you were playing. I definitely tried. Yes, that's good acting.
144|||paragraph 如果我有台词，不管是什么，我都觉得安杰拉内心深处对某事感到沮丧，因为她经常表现得那么不友善又生硬。但也许那天她感到害怕、悲伤或焦虑。所以我只会写下一个与所说内容相配的情感词。这就是为什么我认为你的角色那么有层次，而不是那种单一的恶毒。你总是在扮演你的次要情感。我绝对试过了。是的，那是好演技。
Well, I really saw so much emotion in Pam in just your eyes, Jenna. I thought you were just so good at conveying so much. Really good acting class. Watch Jenna as Pam, guys. Aw, thanks lady. Alison W. from Winnipeg wrote in to say, Jenna, when did you realize your character
145|||Well, I really saw so much emotion in Pam in just your eyes, Jenna. I thought you were just so good at conveying so much. Really good acting class. Watch Jenna as Pam, guys. Aw, thanks lady. Alison W. from Winnipeg wrote in to say, Jenna, when did you realize your character
was a part of one of television's greatest love stories? How did that feel then and now? And Leighton R. wrote in from Folsom, California saying, Pam's relationship with Jim is a fan favorite. How did you and John Krasinski develop the chemistry that made their bond so believable? Lady, I have to tell you, I just saw a trailer for Will Ferrell's new movie with Reese Witherspoon and literally their daughter is at her wedding day doing her vows and she says, you're the Jim to my Pam. What?
146|||是电视史上最伟大的爱情故事的一部分？当时和现在有什么感觉？来自加利福尼亚州福尔索姆的雷顿·R.写信说，帕姆和吉姆的关系是粉丝的最爱。你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基是如何培养出让他们的纽带如此可信的化学反应的？天哪，我必须告诉你，我刚刚看到威尔·法瑞尔和瑞斯·威瑟斯彭合作的新电影的预告片，他们的女儿在婚礼宣誓时竟然说，你就是我的吉姆。什么？
In this movie that is just coming out. Oh my gosh. Isn't that wild? That is nuts. Yeah, that is, I mean, just one example of how ingrained, I feel like into pop culture are Jim and Pam. Yes, yes. And I saw this question as well, Angela,
147|||在这部即将上映的电影里。哦天哪。是不是太疯狂了？太荒谬了。是的，我是说，这只是吉姆和帕姆如何深入流行文化的一个例子。是的，是的。我也看到了这个问题，安杰拉，
and I'm so excited to get to talk about this because people ask all the time about my chemistry with John. And for a long time when the show was on the air and even afterward, people would get upset when they learned we were not a couple in real life. I know, people still wanna believe it. And I did this interview once where I talked about all this in a really clunky way, and I was then misquoted,
148|||我很高兴能谈论这个，因为人们总是问起我和约翰之间的化学反应。在剧集热播期间以及之后的很长一段时间里，人们得知我们在现实生活中并不是情侣时，都会感到难过。我知道，人们还是愿意相信这一点。我曾经做过一次采访，在采访中我以一种非常笨拙的方式谈到了这一切，然后我被断章取义了，
and all these clickbait articles went viral, and the misquote has gone on to be reprinted over and over again. I even saw it in a book, Angela. I mean, I remember this. It was just crazy. Do you want to share the misquote? Yes. Since we're talking about this. I mean, this is the time. I was on Watch What Happens Live, which, by the way, is a show that I love, and Andy Cohen is amazing.
149|||所有这些诱导点击的文章都疯传了，而且这段断章取义的话后来被一次又一次地转载。我甚至在一本书里看到过，安杰拉。我的意思是，我记得这件事。这简直太疯狂了。你想分享一下那段断章取义的话吗？好啊。既然我们在谈论这个。我是说，就是现在。我当时在看《观看发生什么直播》（Watch What Happens Live），顺便说一句，这是一个我很喜欢的节目，安迪·科恩太棒了。
Such a fun show. Also from St. Louis. Yep. So this is no reflection on it. But a fan called in to ask how John and I had such great chemistry while not being a couple in real life. And I said this quote.
150|||一个非常有趣的节目。也是来自圣路易斯。是的。所以这并不代表什么。但有个粉丝打电话来问，在现实生活中不是情侣的情况下，我和约翰是如何拥有如此棒的化学反应的。然后我说了这样一句话。
I looked it up, Ange. Here is my quote. Direct quote. Yes, I said this. Quote, there's like a real part of me that is Pam and a real part of him that's Jim. And those parts of us were genuinely in love with one another. In real life, we aren't totally Pam and totally Jim.
151|||我查过了，安杰。这是我的原话。原话。是的，我说了这个。引号，我身上有一个真正的部分就是帕姆，他身上有一个真正的部分就是吉姆。我们身上的那些部分对彼此产生了真正的爱意。在现实生活中，我们并不完全是帕姆，也不完全是吉姆。
So in real life, we're not like the perfect match. He was like a type of spouse that I had for a long time. He was my partner, and we will always be close because of it. I mean, that makes perfect sense to me. It's a very actor-y answer. It's a little actor-y, it's a little clunky. Well, I mean, I get it though. I hear what you're saying.
152|||所以在现实生活中，我们并不是那种完美的绝配。他就像是我当了很长时间的一种配偶。他是我的搭档，正因为如此，我们将永远保持亲密。我的意思是，这对我来说完全说得通。这是一个非常演员式的回答。有点像演员的回答，有点笨拙。好吧，我是说，我懂的。我明白你的意思。
You're saying that as an actor, the part of you that was Pam, and as an actor, the part of him that was Jim, had a real bond. But you say it's not in real life? Not in real life. Oh, but no, people misquoted it. Well, is it misquoting or is it click baiting? Because... Yeah, it's click baiting. I feel like it was click baity. I mean, I know why it was hard to describe it. It's because you don't want to let people down, right? Yes, I was always afraid to tell people that in real life,
153|||你的意思是，作为一名演员，你身上属于帕姆的部分，以及作为一名演员，他身上属于吉姆的部分，有着真正的纽带。但你说这不是在现实生活中？不是在现实生活中。哦，不过不，人们断章取义了。好吧，这是断章取义还是标题党？因为……是的，这是标题党。我觉得这就是标题党。我的意思是，我知道为什么很难描述它。那是因为你不想让人失望，对吧？是的，我一直害怕告诉人们，在现实生活中，
we're just friends. You know, because the fandom for Jim and Pam is so strong. But yeah, we were just great scene partners, and we had this deep mutual respect for one another. That's it. We never dated or anything, just friends. But oh my goodness, Angela, the clickbait. I know.
154|||我们只是朋友。你知道的，因为吉姆和帕姆的粉丝群体太强大了。但是，是的，我们只是伟大的搭档，我们对彼此有着深深的相互尊重。就是这样。我们从未约会过或什么的，只是朋友。但是哦天哪，安杰拉，那些标题党。我知道。
I woke up to my phone blowing up and it was not just tabloids. This was everywhere. It was like every website and on TV shows. It was insane. Well, it was like people picked it up like it was news, which is bonkers, but I looked up some of the headlines.
155|||我一醒来，手机就炸了，而且不只是小报。到处都是。就像每个网站和电视节目上都有。太疯狂了。好吧，就好像人们把它当成新闻一样接受，这太荒谬了，但我查了一些头条新闻。
Do you wanna hear them? Yes. Is it okay if I read them? Yes, because I read the quote and now look at what all the headlines said. Okay. LA Times, the Los Angeles Times, quote, Jenna Fischer was genuinely in love with Office co-star John Krasinski. I never said that. You never said that! Entertainment Weekly!
156|||你想听听吗？想。我可以读一下吗？可以，因为我读了那句话，现在看看所有的头条新闻都写了什么。好的。《洛杉矶时报》（LA Times），引述，“珍娜·费舍尔对《办公室》联合主演约翰·卡拉辛斯基产生了真挚的爱意。”我从来没说过这话。你从来没说过！《娱乐周刊》（Entertainment Weekly）！
Jenna Fischer reveals she and John Krasinski were genuinely in love while filming The Office. Boy, they really latched on to that genuinely in love thing. Why are you allowed to take three words and turn it into a new context? I don't know. Is what I don't understand. I don't know. Buzzfeed wrote, Jenna Fischer and John Krasinski were genuinely in love while filming The Office and now our hearts are melting.
157|||珍娜·费舍尔透露，她和约翰·卡拉辛斯基在拍摄《办公室》时真心相爱。天哪，他们真的抓着“真心相爱”这句话不放。为什么你们可以截取三个词并把它变成一个新的语境？我不知道。这是我不明白的。我不知道。《Buzzfeed》写道，珍娜·费舍尔和约翰·卡拉辛斯基在拍摄《办公室》时真心相爱，现在我们的心都要融化了。
Yes. Now we're adding emotion to it. Yes, and it goes on and on like that. All the articles just pulled the phrase genuinely in love as if the context of what I said wasn't important. I never said we were genuinely in love. Yeah, so here's the thing. When something like that happens to you
158|||是的。现在我们又给它加上了情感。是的，文章就这样没完没了地继续下去。所有的文章都直接抽出了“真心相爱”这个短语，就好像我说话的语境一点都不重要一样。我从来没说过我们真心相爱。是的，所以情况是这样的。当这样的事情发生在你身上时，
and your phone's blowing up, what do you do? I know. I know. What do you do? Now it's like, it's so crazy because no matter how much you like try to be like correct it, it is out in the world. Yeah, well here's what I did.
159|||而且你的手机爆了，你该怎么办？我知道。我知道。你该怎么办？现在这太疯狂了，因为不管你多么努力地去澄清，它已经流传于世了。是的，好吧，我是这么做的。
I called John and he answers the phone, and he goes, Hey. Oh no, he gave you a Stacey. He had seen it all. Oh, his phone had been blowing up too. And I was like, um, John, I was click baited. And he said, oh, I know, I read the whole quote. And you guys, you have to know that me and Lee
160|||我给约翰打电话，他接了电话，然后他说，嘿。哦不，他给了你一个“斯黛西”。他已经把这一切都看过了。哦，他的手机也快被打爆了。然后我说，嗯，约翰，我被标题党坑了。他说，哦，我知道，我把整段话都读了。你们大家，你们必须知道我和李
are good friends with John and Emily. Yeah, you guys have done vacations together, you've done play dates with your kids. Yes, and John says, you know, I actually have a press junket coming up. So I'm happy to say that you were misquoted. I know, I was like, John, no, everyone's gonna ask you about this now at this press junket.
161|||跟约翰和艾米丽是好朋友。是的，你们一起度过假，你们的孩子也一起玩过。是的，约翰说，你知道，我实际上有一个即将到来的媒体见面会。所以我很高兴能说你被断章取义了。我知道，当时我想，约翰，不，现在每个人在这个媒体见面会上都会问你这个问题。
He said, don't worry about it. I'll say you were misquoted. And I said, that's great. Just simple. She was misquoted, guys. Yes. Okay. Well, that did not go well either.
162|||他说，别担心。我会说你被断章取义了。我说，那太好了。很简单。大家，她被断章取义了。是的。好吧，结果并不顺利。
After he tries to set the record straight, all these headlines come out that say, John Krasinski says he was not in love with Jenna Fisher, but all the stories still imply that I was in love with him. So that news cycle goes out. That's not helping. No, and so now my phone is blowing up again and John calls me and I'm like, hey. And he's like, I am so sorry. I was trying to help.
163|||在他试图澄清事实之后，所有这些头条新闻都出来了，上面写着，约翰·卡拉辛斯基说他没有爱上珍娜·费舍尔，但所有的报道仍然暗示我爱上了他。于是新闻循环就这么播出了。这毫无帮助。不，所以现在我的手机又炸了，约翰打电话给我，我说，嘿。他说，我真的很抱歉。我只是想帮忙。
And at that point I said, just forget it. Just forget it. I'm never getting rid of this. And of course, here I am talking about it again. And I guess probably opening myself up to more of this clickbait bullshit. I guess my long answer to the fan question, when did I realize that I was part of one
164|||而在那个时候我说，算了吧。算了吧。我永远也摆脱不了这个了。当然，我又在这里谈论这件事了。我想我大概是在自找苦吃，去迎合更多这种狗屁标题党。我想我对粉丝问题的长篇大论是：什么时候我意识到自己是电视史上最伟大的爱情故事的一部分？
of television's greatest love stories? And how did that feel then and now? Well, I realized pretty early on that people have a strong attachment to Jim and Pam. But I never really thought about how that attachment might become sort of weird with like... Global news stories. ...clickbait articles and stuff. Yeah, I mean, that is weird. And it's kind of a drag because,
165|||当时和现在有什么感觉？嗯，我很早就意识到人们对吉姆和帕姆有着强烈的依恋。但我从没想过这种依恋会变得有些奇怪，比如……全球新闻报道……诱导点击的文章之类的。是的，我是说，这太奇怪了。这有点让人扫兴，因为，
I mean, love Jim and Pam, love them, but this part of it is a little bit of a bummer. And you know, I never had that with Rain. I don't think Dwayne Angela quite packs the punch like jam. Well, you know, I remember early in my career, for a really long time, there was this misquote about me that was in an article I was doing about animal rescue. And I had said in my interview that during my time
166|||我是说，爱吉姆和帕姆，爱他们，但这一部分确实有点让人沮丧。你知道，我跟雷恩从没有过这种经历。我觉得“德韦恩”和“安杰拉”产生的火花可比不上“杰姆”（吉姆和帕姆）。嗯，你知道，我记得在我职业生涯的早期，很长一段时间里，有一个关于我的误传，那是我在做一篇关于动物救援的文章中出现的。我在采访中说过，在
in animal rescue, I said that I had rescued and rehabilitated and found homes for 12 cats. Well, the article just said I had 12 cats. So like for years when I would do other interviews, they would ask me about my 12 cats. And I would have to say I don't have 12 cats. So weird the things that somehow get distorted and people latch onto.
167|||我从事动物救援期间，我救援、康复并为12只猫找到了家。好吧，那篇文章只是说我有12只猫。所以好几年里，当我接受其他采访时，他们都会问我关于我的12只猫的事。而我不得不说我没有12只猫。有些事情不知怎么就被扭曲了，人们还紧抓不放，真是太奇怪了。
This is nowhere, nowhere like what you've been through. But one time in an interview, someone asked me what my favorite food was and I said, I love tacos. I don't know you to love tacos. I don't know, I was on the spot. I was like, it was like on a red carpet, you know, like what's your favorite food?
168|||这跟你经历的完全没法比。但有一次在采访中，有人问我最喜欢什么食物，我说，我喜欢塔可（玉米卷）。我不知道你这么喜欢塔可。我不知道，我当时被问懵了。就像在红毯上一样，你知道的，就类似问你最喜欢的食物是什么？
And I was like, I don't know, tacos. I mean, I can't tell you how many times people ask me like, hey, we know you love tacos. Do you ever arrive places and they've put tacos like in your dressing room because they googled you and they know how much you love them? No, but I did have a gift basket one time that had taco seasoning in it. That's what I'm talking about. That's what I'm saying.
169|||然后我说，我不知道，塔可。我是说，我无法告诉你多少次人们问我，嘿，我们知道你喜欢塔可。你有没有到达某个地方，他们在你的化妆间里放了塔可，因为他们谷歌了你，知道你有多喜欢它们？没有，不过我有一次确实收到过一个里面有塔可调味料的礼品篮。这就是我说的意思。这就是我想说的。
Well, I think it's on my Wikipedia page. It might be. Your love of tacos and my 12 cats. I said it one time. And my genuinely in love. Oh, lady. Well, listen, the bottom line is I am really proud of the work that John and I did on the show, really proud.
170|||好吧，我想它在我的维基百科页面上。可能吧。你对塔可的爱和我的12只猫。我说过一次。还有我“真心相爱”。哦，天哪。好吧，听着，最重要的是，我为我和约翰在剧中完成的工作感到骄傲，真的非常骄傲。
And I feel so lucky to have had John as my scene partner all those years. I couldn't have done it with anyone else. This I know. We shared a brain when it came to Jim and Pam. Yeah. We did. It was really special.
171|||我觉得很幸运，这些年来约翰一直是我的搭档。没有别人我能做到这一点。这一点我很清楚。说到吉姆和帕姆，我们心有灵犀。是的。我们确实如此。这真的很特别。
Yeah, and it is really cool that you're part of this iconic television lore, this amazing couple that so many people love. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I'm really glad we finally talked about that. Next question is from Rachel N. in North Carolina. Rachel says, I'm asking this question on behalf of my husband Raj. Do you think Pam would have married Roy if Jim had not confessed his love and transferred to Stanford? Oh, I love this question. No, I don't. I don't think Pam would have married Roy.
172|||是的，你能成为这个标志性电视传说、这个让这么多人喜爱的惊艳情侣的一部分，真的很酷。是的。好吧，我很高兴我们终于谈了那个。下一个问题来自北卡罗来纳州的瑞秋·N。瑞秋说，我代我丈夫拉杰问这个问题。如果吉姆没有表白并调到斯坦福，你觉得帕姆会嫁给罗伊吗？哦，我喜欢这个问题。不，不会。我不认为帕姆会嫁给罗伊。
I think she would have eventually been honest with herself, like as the wedding was approaching. I think it's why she wasn't super bummed to have a three-year engagement. Yeah. You know? You know, if you look at Pam and Roy, none of them were trying to push that boulder up the mountain.
173|||我觉得随着婚礼的临近，她最终会对自己坦诚的。我想这就是为什么她对于订婚三年并不是特别沮丧的原因。对吧？你知道的？你知道，如果你看看帕姆和罗伊，他们谁都没有试图把那块巨石推上山。
They were just fine to kind of just stay in this sort of purgatory place in their relationship. I mean, look at how quickly Pam and Jim get married after they get engaged. Yeah, you know? Yeah. So I don't think she would have. No, I agree. Next question is from Carrie B. in Tacoma, Washington. Carrie says Pam's occasionally random friendship with Dwight is one of my favorite character relationships on the show. Pam and Dwight were always funny and yet somehow also sincere.
174|||他们只是满足于在他们的关系中保持这种炼狱般的状态。我是说，看看帕姆和吉姆订婚后结婚有多快。对吧，你知道的？是的。所以我觉得她不会。是的，我同意。下一个问题来自华盛顿州塔科马的凯瑞·B。凯瑞说，帕姆和德韦恩偶尔那种随性的友谊是我剧中最喜欢的角色关系之一。帕姆和德韦恩总是很有趣，但不知何故也很真诚。
Jenna, what is your favorite Pam and Dwight moment? Oh my gosh, there are so many. I mean, I love the injury. That's kind of where it starts. Yeah. I loved vandalism. But my favorite storyline with Dwight is Pam's replacement. It's where Pam is super pregnant,
175|||珍娜，你最喜欢的帕姆和德韦恩的时刻是什么？哦天哪，有太多了。我是说，我喜欢那场受伤的戏。那可以说是这一切的开始。是的。我喜欢破坏公物那集。但我最喜欢的关于德韦恩的剧情线是帕姆的替代者。那是帕姆怀孕期间，
and she realizes that Dwight is the only person who's being honest with her because everyone's telling her how gorgeous she is. And then Jim is telling her that he doesn't find Kathy attractive. I actually pulled a clip because this scene in particular was one of my favorite to do with Rain. I know it sounds nuts,
176|||她意识到德韦恩是唯一一个对她实话实说的人，因为其他人都在告诉她她有多么华丽。然后吉姆告诉她，他觉得凯茜并不可爱。我实际上截取了一个片段，因为这场戏尤其是我和雷恩合作时最喜欢的戏之一。我知道这听起来很疯狂，
but I think Dwight is the only one who's telling me the truth. Dwight, am I hot right now? Why would I or anyone else think that you're hot right now? I can't impregnate you, and that's the driving force between male, attraction. What about before was I attractive before? Yeah, you're at your most attractive when you were 24 with a slight gradual decline and a steep drop-off when you got pregnant for the first time gradual recovery and Well now obviously you're an all-time low
177|||但我认为德韦恩是唯一一个对我说实话的人。德韦恩，我现在性感吗？为什么我或其他任何人会觉得你现在性感？我无法让你怀孕，而那是男性吸引力的驱动力。那之前呢，我之前有吸引力吗？是的，你在24岁时最具吸引力，之后逐渐走下坡路，在你第一次怀孕时急剧下降，然后逐渐恢复，好吧，现在显然你处于历史最低点。
Hmm I think Jim's lying to me about not being attracted to Kathy. You think Jim's lying? That's so cute. I know he's lying. Five bucks if you can get him to admit it. Done. I never touch a pregnant woman. Yep, that's the Dwight I need.
178|||嗯，我觉得吉姆对我说他觉得凯茜不可爱是在撒谎。你觉得吉姆在撒谎？太可爱了。我知道他在撒谎。如果你能让他承认，我给你五块钱。成交。我从不碰孕妇。是的，这正是我需要的德韦恩。
I love it. I love that scene. You know, we all have that friend who can really give it to you straight. Yeah. And it doesn't hurt your feelings and you actually need it because the rest of the world is gaslighting you. Yeah. And I love that scene. And then of course this episode has the whole Mike Tibbetts runner, which was so much fun to shoot.
179|||我太喜欢了。我喜欢那一幕。你知道，我们都有那种能真正对你直言不讳的朋友。是的。而且这不会伤你的感情，你实际上需要它，因为世界的其余部分都在对你进行精神虐待。是的。我爱那一幕。然后当然这一集有整个迈克·蒂贝茨的支线，拍起来太有趣了。
So I will have to call that my favorite. All right. Our last question is from Laura P in Wisconsin. Laura says, Jenna, did you ever find it annoying that you are most known slash recognized for playing Pam? Do you wish you were recognized for other work? No. It is my honor to have played Pam. I'm getting choked up.
180|||所以我不得不称其为我最喜欢的。好的。我们的最后一个问题来自威斯康星州的劳拉·P。劳拉说，珍娜，你有没有觉得因为饰演帕姆而最为人所知/认可是一件很烦人的事？你希望因为其他作品而被认可吗？不。能够饰演帕姆是我的荣幸。我哽咽了。
I don't know why. What a legacy. I do not need more. I don't. I don't need more. I remember being at Greg Daniel's house at dinner and the show was coming to an end. And I said, I have no more career goals.
181|||我不知道为什么。多么伟大的传奇。我不需要更多了。我真的不需要。我记得在格雷格·丹尼尔斯的家吃晚饭，剧集即将结束。我说，我没有更多的职业目标了。
This was it. I wanted to play a character that meant something to people on an ensemble television comedy, and I did it. That's all I wanted when I came to Los Angeles. So it's my honor to be remembered for doing that thing. I mean, who gets to do that? What a gift. What a gift.
182|||这就是全部了。我想在一个群戏电视喜剧中扮演一个对人们有意义的角色，我做到了。这就是我来到洛杉矶时想要的全部。所以能因为做那件事而被人们记住是我的荣幸。我是说，谁能做到这一点？多么棒的礼物。多么棒的礼物。
I do want to win a Tony Award though. I do have a new career goal. Well, you know what? A late in life new career goal. We all have goals for our seasons of life. Yeah. And your goal for this season is a Tony. Well, I want to end with this wonderful letter.
183|||不过我确实想赢得托尼奖。我确实有一个新的职业目标。好吧，你知道吗？人生晚期的一个新职业目标。我们所有人对人生的各个阶段都有目标。是的。而你这个阶段的目标是一个托尼奖。好吧，我想以这封美妙的信来结束。
It's going to be our final word here on the All About Pam Beasley episode. It's from Allison C. in Florida, and Allison wrote in and said this, When I first watched The Office in middle school, Pam was one of the first characters I ever fully saw myself in. My dad describes me as having quiet strength, and I don't think there's a better phrase to describe Pam Beasley. Watching her blossom as the show went on gave me hope for myself. In the final episode Pam quoted, it would just make my heart soar if someone out there saw this and said to herself, Love yourself. Conquer your fears. Just go after what you want and act fast because life just isn't that long. Pam would be proud to know that a little girl watching latched on to those words.
184|||这将是我们关于“全景解密帕姆·比斯利”这一集的最后一句话。它来自佛罗里达州的艾森·C。，艾森写道：当我第一次在初中看《办公室》时，帕姆是我第一个能完全看到自己身影的角色之一。我爸爸形容我有着安静的力量，我认为没有比这更好的词来形容帕姆·比斯利了。随着剧集的播出，看着她绽放给了我自己希望。在最后一集里，帕姆引用道：“如果外面的某个人看到这一幕并对自己说，‘爱自己。战胜恐惧。去追求你想要的东西，赶快行动，因为生命真的没那么长’，这会让我的心飞扬。”帕姆会为一个小女孩看着看着就记住了这些话而感到骄傲。
I even printed it out and tacked it on my bedroom wall where it remained all throughout my high school years. That little girl now has her first office job post college and loves the office more than ever and that little girl fully believes that Pam was the main subject of the documentary. Oh thank you, Allison. She says, that's my personal soapbox. From the quiet, creative girls all around the world. Thank you, Jenna, for showing us that there's a lot of beauty in ordinary things. That is kind of the point after all. Wow.
185|||我甚至把它打印出来贴在我的卧室墙上，它一直挂在我的整个高中岁月里。那个小女孩现在拥有了她大学毕业后的第一份办公室工作，并且比以往任何时候都更爱《办公室》，那个小女孩坚信帕姆是这部纪录片的主角。哦，谢谢你，艾森。她说，这就是我的个人阵地。献给全世界所有安静、有创意的女孩们。谢谢你，珍娜，向我们展示了平凡事物中蕴含着许多美丽。毕竟，这才是重点。哇。
Oh my gosh. That really moved me. You know, that quote, I said it, I didn't write it. That is the heart of Greg Daniels. That's the message he wanted people to take from this character and this beautiful arc that he crafted along with all the other writers for me to play. And I mean letters like that are exactly why I don't need to be remembered for doing anything else. It's just beautiful. Yeah, it really is. It is. Well, we just love you guys so much. Thank
186|||哦天哪。这真的感动了我。你知道，那句话，是我说的，不是我写的。那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的内核。那是他希望人们从这个角色以及他和所有其他编剧为我精心打造的美丽弧光中体会到的信息。我是说，像这样的信件正是我不需要因为做其他事情而被记住的原因。这简直太美妙了。是的，确实如此。是的。好吧，我们太爱你们了。非常
you so much for listening to Office Ladies and Office Ladies 6.0 and your support over the years and just these great questions. We just love doing this and thank you. Thank you so much and thank you Sam, Cassie and Angela for my birthday celebration. You know last year I turned 50 and I didn't get a big birthday because I was actually in chemotherapy for my 50th birthday. Yeah. So this year is an extra special milestone and you've kicked it off in the best way. Thank you. Well, let's go eat some cake. Let's do it. You guys have a great week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
187|||感谢你们收听《Office Ladies》和《Office Ladies 6.0》，感谢你们多年来的支持以及这些棒极了的问题。我们非常喜欢做这个，谢谢你们。非常感谢，也谢谢山姆、卡茜和安杰拉为我庆祝生日。你知道去年我50岁了，我没有过一个盛大的生日，因为我50岁生日的时候实际上在接受化疗。是的。所以今年是一个格外特别的里程碑，你们以最好的方式开启了它。谢谢。好吧，我们去吃蛋糕吧。走吧。祝大家有个愉快的一周。谢谢收听《Office Ladies》。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
188|||《Office Ladies》是奥德赛（Odyssey）的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安杰拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡茜·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和利亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由克里斯·巴塞尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubberree》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。